If we printed t-shirts that hashtag swim mask
or hashtag team swim mask,
you could probably sell a thousand of them.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
(upbeat music ends)
All right, greetings to the seekers among us.
You, me, us, y'all, everyone.
May this sonic pixelated vibration find you well,
amidst the chaos and confusion that is life.
My God given name is Rich Roll.
Once again, in Vulcan mind-meld,
in conversational communion
with the high-minded literary line himself.
The child rearing Dodger fan.
Global citizen of the oceans.
Conscious advocate for all things ecological preservation.
My copilot On all things Roll On.
Duke of Santa Monica Bay,
Mr. Adam Skolnick.
How you doing, man?
Wow.
How about that?
Your intros
I just outdid myself.
You were already great.
You were already great. You topped you.
I did.
What am I gonna do next time?
You know, you could go full absurdist.
You could go full Charlie Kaufman.
It's already, yeah, getting a little bit surreal.
Before you answer my question now.
Yes
I should mention, Roll On, for those who are
a little bit newer to the show
is our
bimonthly.
That's correct, Right?
Bimonthly?
Does bimonthly mean every other month or twice a month?
Yes. I think it's...
I never know.
Twice a month. Bimonthly is twice a month.
It is bimonthly, man.
I would say it's mostly bimonthly.
Generally bimonthly.
What is every other month
then?
I think that's bimonthly too.
I think it can be either one.
(Adam laughs)
I don't know that's confusing.
Anyway. Either way,
Roll-on is our opportunity to kind of shift focus away
from our traditional fare here on the RRP,
which is evergreen deep dives
with some of the world's most interesting minds.
And instead hone in on matters of contemporaneous interest.
We spin a little show and tell,
got some interesting show and tell today.
Yes.
We share some wins of the week,
and we land our little twin prop seaplane
with listener questions dropped on our voicemail
at (424) 235-4626.
Write that phone number down.
Now you can answer my question.
Yeah, well, I was just going
to say after that first paragraph that you
read that was so glowing...
I did read it.
For people that think that I just came up with that
on the spot.
I did write that down.
He writes these.
And then the second paragraph saying my traditional fare,
evergreen deep dives with some of the world's most
interesting minds instead Adam's here.
(both laugh)
I like how you just pivot
That's how I took it.
immediately to the self-deprecating,
interpretation of that.
Yeah. We're not gonna do that this week.
We're gonna go towards the binal.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
This week we'll just talk
about Adam swimming in the Santa Monica Bay.
Yeah, we'll talk about masks. We'll make fun of that.
We'll Do what we always do.
I don't know. I don't know how these things go.
Okay, I'm doing pretty good, man.
I have this month
run over 80 miles,
which is not, listen,
for people who actually run,
that's not that great.
That's actually, that's quite a bit of running.
Yeah, I mean, you know,
you have to run a lot to get to 80.
Yeah.
And then scram over 10...
You have to run 80 to get to 80.
This is starting off hot.
I know.
Over 10 miles of open water swimming in August.
That's amazing.
My goal was to,
was to kind of get to those benchmarks,
whether that's a good goal or not.
Uh huh.
And then I have an Alcatraz swim coming up on
September 11th.
Nice.
The South End Rowing Club.
You know about these clubs?
Yeah. Yeah, I've done the Alcatraz Swim.
Right.
So the South End Rowing Club has like a,
they do their own thing and they,
they have the the guys in boats or women
in boats kind of on either side,
and you swim in the lane.
And it's, I did it before,
when World of Open Water Swimming
was doing their summit up there
and Antonio Arguelles is coming to the bay,
which is kind of one of his home training grounds as well,
home away from home.
He's either in Los Ustachas in Mexico city,
the river there,
or he's swimming in the Santa, La Jolla
or the San Francisco bay.
Those are his three main training grounds.
And he is a member of the rowing club.
And he's the guest of honor, this Alcatraz swim.
So he invited me up there. And whenever.
Remind people who he is.
Antonio Argulles.
We talked about him the other time but.
He is a
a two time Guinness world record holder
of open water swimmer.
So he has the, he's the oldest ever,
and the seventh overall ever to complete the ocean seven,
which is the seven major channels
part of an ocean sevens group.
You've had Kim Chambers on the show.
She was the sixth, fifth or sixth.
And then Antonio was right after.
He did it at 58 years of age making him the oldest.
He's also the oldest to ever swim the double Catalina.
He did that in 2019
at 60.
Stanford alum.
Stanford alum,
Mexican entrepreneur, and government official.
So this Alcatraz swim, you're doing it
without a wetsuit right?
Right.
So the first time I did it, I was in a wetsuit
and; much to Antonio's enduring shame,
Yeah, you cannot save face and do Alcatraz in a wetsuit.
No, but speaking of face, I will be in swim mask.
You will. Yeah, so-
(Adam laughs)
everybody in the bay area turn up
at what's it called?
Ocean Park right there where it finishes.
I forget what it's called.
Aquatic Park.
Aquatic Park, right.
To get your pics with Skolnick in the mask,
a rare opportunity of you
in the wild with the mask.
In the public with your people.
Yeah, listen, if you're there,
I'm going to slow motion rise up,
(Rich laughs)
so there won't be any footage of this,
but I will slow motion rise up.
And so that's it. So I am going to shift.
I'm still gonna keep running a little bit,
but I'll do more swims.
You know, the problem is I've been swimming
in, you know, 66 degree water.
Yeah, it's a little bit different.
I think I've told this story before,
but I did the Alcatraz swim many years ago
when I was living in San Francisco.
My roommate at the time; Gavin Hollis,
who swam at LSU,
we did it with a bunch of friends.
We did it without wetsuits.
And I think it was, it might've been New Year's.
Like, I think it was winter when we did it.
Nice. 54.
If memory recall; you know, if my memory serves me.
My memory is not great.
And all I remember, well, I remember three things.
First of all, it's really freaking cold.
At Winter.
My hands and my feet went completely numb.
So you feel like you're swimming with your fists?
Like you can't feel your hands at all.
Yeah.
The second thing, and I say this
as somebody who's done quite a bit
of a open water swimming
in many different areas around the world,
it's very, and you've done it before, right?
Yeah.
It's kind of scary when you're in the,
you kind of rear your head up when you're
in the middle of it.
It's not that far.
It's only like a kilometer and a half
or something like that.
It's a mile. 1.27 miles.
Right. So it's not a great distance.
It's not that far.
But you're in a shipping lane.
You are.
But they have,
And you have that set-
you can kind of smell the fuel
Yeah, it's definitely industrial.
and you kind of lift your head when you're halfway into it
And you're like, holy shit!
Like, this does not feel safe.
Right. These guys; when you have the rowing club though,
you know, they bring out those old wooden boats
and they are in kayaks and those boats.
Right.
And they are on either side of you, so.
And they time it in between the tides, right?
So right, right at the beginning
of like the slack tide or whatever.
So the faster you are, the less the tide effects you.
The slower you are, the more it affects you.
'Cause the tide starts
to pick up and push you out towards the bridge.
Oh, is that right?
And so I just remember,
good to know.
people who were struggling
ended up down by the safe way.
(Adam laughs)
Like it pushes you towards the marina.
And that becomes a problem.
If you're fast, it doesn't really seem to affect you.
The final thing that I recall is that; you know,
I don't know who's organizing these races these days,
but back in the day,
whoever was in charge of this thing had a dog.
I think a Labrador.
I'm pretty sure it was a lab
who loved doing the swim.
And I just remember in Aquatic Park,
or actually on the boat and the ferry
on the way over the dog being super excited.
And then afterwards,
like the dog just running around like,
"This is the greatest thing
in the world, swimming Alcatraz"
and the dog beat like half the field.
The dog would definitely beat me.
Dog paddling from Alcatraz to Aquatic Park
like did just fine.
It was not a problem.
That's amazing.
That's my big fear,
you would have obviously easily beaten the dog.
I'm not sure I'd beat the dog.
I'm not that fast.
Maybe if you traded your mask
for a proper pair of goggles that would save you
a little bit of time.
You know what, I've traded-
But now at this point, you can never wear goggles.
No, I like it.
Especially with the industrial water.
I think we need merch. A t-shirt with you
in the masks saying Skolnick.
We'll get to my take on merch.
I will say the last thing I'll say about it
is that my time,
so I've ditched the rash guard,
I'm trying to get a little bit quicker.
I am using the pull bouie a lot in the open water,
because I'm practicing mostly
for Catalina.
And that makes me a little quicker,
but I'm not kicking at all.
So, I don't know how that'll affect,
but I'm at like 2-0-5 per hundred,
and that's, if I take a break to pee or whatever.
Like, I'm not stopping my thing.
It's not that great,
but it's not terrible.
Like, I've been slower before.
In a wetsuit, I'd be under two minutes per hundred.
I'm comfortable if I can get to two minutes per hundred.
I don't know what you think of that time,
and what any of that?
I mean, you know, do you want me to sound like
an asshole.
(both laughing)
You're not impressed, are you? (Adam laughs)
I'm not going to say anything.
I'm happy for you.
It's exciting. It's all good, man.
(Adam laughs)
No, but I mean how do I get faster?
I need a whole rework, don't I?
I can take you down to the pool and we can do
some working out.
I've been getting into the pool.
I swim now four or five days in a row.
You told me, that's exciting.
Yeah, so I just put in 37 hundred before coming here
in an hour.
Geez.
Because you only; well, here's the thing,
like I haven't swum literally in like a year,
but my back has been acting up.
I'm working with this great PT right now
who's got me on a path towards; you know, resolving this.
But one of the commitments that I've made
is to really lay off the running.
Which I hate doing, 'cause I love running so much.
So it takes everything in my power to not run.
And, and I'm now decided, you know,
so I'm going to put all that energy
into the pool.
And it's required me to have
to get organized because most of the pools are shut down
or have limited hours.
There is a great facility;
It's like a half an hour drive from my house and you got
to book lanes like well in advance.
So I've just been really organized and proactive
about making sure that I reserve time
and you only get one an hour, right?
So you get an hour in one lane and you have the lane
to yourself, though? That's nice.
You get an hour in one lane.
Yeah, you get the lane to yourself.
There's a couple days coming up
where I booked double sessions.
Oh, wow.
I don't know if you're allowed to book two in a row,
but I'm going to see if I can get away with it.
So I'm really gonna put my energy
into getting my swim back in shape.
And I got to say, it feels really good to be back
in the water.
I mean, I'm really out of swimming shape,
but I'm excited to give it a try.
And one of the kind of catalyst for this is,
I don't know if I'm allowed to say this publicly,
I don't know.
I don't know why I couldn't, but
the Malibu Triathlon
is coming up soon.
Which is an annual event.
And they do this thing every year;
They have a celebrity division.
Yes!
(Rich laughs)
Which is traditionally like television stars.
And like Disney puts a team together.
I remember like Matthew McConaughey
did it several years ago.
David Duchovny generally shows up.
Anyway,
Alexi Pappas;, friend of the pod,
put a team together, asked me to join in a relay.
So I'm going to do the swim,
Alexi's going to do the run,
And Mary Cain, also friend of the pod,
is going to do the cycling portion.
You might win it!
So we are the celebrities you've never heard of.
(Rich laughs)
They're like, what should be the name of the team?
And I was like "Three Celebrities You've Never Heard Of,"
that should be the name of our team.
Like, nobody knows who we are, you know, but-
People do.
At least we're athletes. So, we'll see what happens.
So I thought, you know, I should probably get back
in the pool if I'm gonna do this.
It's funny that you say that.
I got contacted by the celebrity division.
Did you?
Speaking of people who aren't famous
in the non celebrities in the celebrity-
And they asked me if I'd do it.
And; first, I committed to doing the whole thing.
I didn't even have a bike.
I mean, I have a single-speed fixie type bike,
but I don't have a bike that I train on
or anything like that.
So are you going to do it?
I; originally, I had said yes, but it's just going
to be too tough going up to Alcatraz and then coming back.
It's just going to-
'cause we're doing a little road trip with the family
on the way up.
It's just going to be too tough to do. And so I said no.
I'm going to make a donation to children's hospital instead,
instead of raising the money.
Yeah, there's a fundraising piece to this.
I don't really know that much about it yet,
but I'll let everyone know when we figure that out.
I was flattered.
I love the fact that you got asked to be
in the celebrity
I know!
division of the Malibu Triathlon.
Has to be a fan of yours running the VIP.
I don't know, it's great, man.
I'm bummed that you're not going to do it now.
Well, I wish, I didn't know you were going to do it.
Well, I just figured this out over the weekend.
Okay.
Yeah. Or over the last couple of days,
but it should be fun.
Yeah, I was going to do the whole thing.
It's prompted me to get back in the pool,
which feels good.
Yeah, it's not a very long one.
It's a half mile swim, 17 mile ride, and four mile run.
It's; like, ridiculously short.
Yeah.
(both laugh)
The next one
it's mask appropriate,
The real one is like the Olympic distance, right?
The international distance?
What do you mean by real?
The next day?
Yeah, they have, it's a couple of days.
Like, I think, yeah, they have the sprint distance,
they have the Olympic distance.
Which is kind of the traditional, you know,
triathlon distance for, you know, the races
that are out there.
Distinct from like the iron man world and all of that.
But, also, Zuma turned one.
He did. We had a bit of a small gathering.
It was weird because it's Delta time,
so we had it in two waves.
We had a few families come in the first wave
and a few come in the second wave.
Heats. He had two heats?
We had two heats.
For this birthday celebration.
And at one point Zuma just went and tried
to make a break for it and just started
to, like, walk out out the gate.
Uh huh.
And I've kind of followed him and I said,
"Should we, bro? Should we?"
And he's like, "Should we? Should we go?
Should we leave this behind."
He's going to ghost his own party.
But in the end he turned around.
So I followed him.
I follow him everywhere.
Yeah. That's the way it goes.
It's fun, man.
He's walking, he's talking a little bit,
you know, it's a good time.
It's; you know, it gives you all the feels.
Cool, man.
Yeah.
And you were in Chicago?
I was in Chicago, gave a couple talks.
It's been like over two years since I've given a keynote.
It was with this company called Dealer Inspire
that's in Naperville, outside of Chicago.
So, it was an opportunity to travel and meet a bunch
of cool people.
The organization was,
it was organized by this guy,
Joe Chura, who's the CEO of Dealer Inspire.
And it was followed the following day by this; kind of,
all day outdoor event called "Go,"
where there was a 5k run and there
was, like, jujitsu,
Oh, cool.
instruction and all kinds of cool stuff.
So it was fun.
it was good to get out of LA and be
in the Midwest and meet some new people and
shake off the cobwebs and give a keynote.
But it also produced quite a bit of anxiety
in me, because it's been so long since I've; kind of,
given a talk and my life is very different
from the last time I was on that circuit.
So I had to kind of rewrite and rethink
what I wanted to talk about.
Was is it been that long because of Covid or
has it been because of you've chosen not to do it?
Yeah, Covid like eviscerated the whole speaking thing.
Right. Right.
So now it seems to; you know, be kicking up again.
Although I was supposed to go to Park City
in a couple of weeks for this song summit thing
where I was going
to interview Jason Isbell and Shaun White,
and we just found out today that they're canceling that
because of Covid.
So everything is tentative, at the moment.
But that trip was book-ended by multiple pods on each side.
So I was on this jag of just crazy workaholism
that left me very depleted and reflecting
on the fact that I'm, basically,
an introvert by nature who can be temporarily extroverted.
Like I am doing right now, or I have to do
if I'm giving a talk with a bunch of people or just being
around a lot of people.
Like I can like gear up and embody
that energy and, you know, provide the experience
that, you know, they're looking for.
But then I have to kind of retreat back
to my cave and, like, lick my wounds and recover.
And I didn't really get an opportunity to do that.
So it left me like really tired.
And also,
reflecting a little bit more
on what we talked about in the last Roll On
about workflow efficiencies and how to, you know,
hold onto this stuff a little bit loosely
and empower my team better and be a better manager,
So I can free up some of my time.
So I took a couple of days off this past week to, you know,
kind of recharge the batteries.
I'm feeling good. I'm back in the pool.
I don't know what to tell you. Like I think,
I think all is good.
And you dodged the mountain lion.
I did.
In your neighborhood.
I did, yeah.
There was a mountain lion attack just the other day.
Literally in my neighborhood.
Yes!
Like just down the street,
a mountain lion attacked a small boy.
The mom ended up fighting it off.
It's this crazy story.
She was like punching it with her bare fist, I guess.
And they ended up destroying that animal.
It was a cub, right?
It was like 60 pound, it was a juvenile.
Yeah, I guess it was a smaller one.
65 pound juvenile.
And then they found a couple more that were tagged.
This one wasn't tagged and they relocated them.
It made me think like,
couldn't they have relocated this one and tagged it?
So, P-54 was the mother from what I read,
and she was collared.
And so it's not even a tag,
it's like a full collar.
And she had just had cubs and
the thinking is both these were the cubs because,
Yeah.
that one kind of got the boy
and the mother
was able to fight him off.
If it was a full grown mountain lion,
the mother probably wouldn't have been able to do much.
And then they found it kind of crouched.
Like, the game warden found it crouched down.
And there was no collar and it was aggressive
and he assumed-
Yeah, but couldn't they have just tranqued it?
So, I don't know.
So after they shot, after he shot that animal,
the two others kind of came out;
the collard one with another juvenile,
And so that's why they think both of them
all three are together.
And then they did some DNA testing and they found out
that the animal they shot did have the boys skin and blood
on his claws and all that.
Anyway, the thinking usually is with cats and animals
like this, if they get a taste for it,
especially young, that it could become the type
of nuisance animal that's not just turning over garbage,
but it's actually hurting people.
And so they err on the side of protecting people.
That's what the game wardens always do.
And they take their criticism for it.
I think in this sense, you can't; I mean,
the game warden was worried
about the five-year-old boy and all that.
Yeah. I understand that.
It just feels like they could have relocated it somewhere.
Where maybe, you know, to an area
that doesn't encroach on exburbs or suburbs.
I mean, one of the arguments here,
one of the conversations around this,
is this is a result of encroaching; you know-
No doubt.
Habitats.
but this area where this happened
is not that; like, it's kind of been the way it's been
for quite some time.
I wonder if these are the same animals that were up on,
remember in Malibu there was that scene?
Did you see like someone
in their house, like up above Big Rock was inside.
It was a father and his like teenage daughter,
and they were videoing. I don't know if you saw this?
It was like a viral video, around the pool.
I did see that.
But Big Rock is quite far from where-
They'll range that far.
Do they have that?
Oh, yeah. They'll go that far.
Do they?
Oh yeah.
It's interesting.
I mean, I run trails all around where
this mountain line was seen and I've never once seen one.
I know they're around.
Let me Google mountain lion range.
Yeah. How far they wander.
This is live googling, folks.
I know, yeah.
Mountain lion range.
The kid is going to be fine. Although he was a wounded.
I guess that it was a juvenile, about 65 pounds.
He had wounds, the kid had wounds
to his head, neck, and upper torso.
But I think he's going to be okay.
The kid's gonna be okay?
Yeah.
They're saying
that it'll travel eight kilometers a day and up.
And eight kilometers a day, but
Do they return to some kind of hub or do they
just meander?
This one is saying 20 miles.
might be their total range.
So, that's 20 square miles.
Right.
So Big Rock would be going over this peak and
down the other side.
I think it would be in it's range.
It's definitely in the range.
Yeah.
I think you've probably
e-biked up that exact territory.
(Rich laughs)
E-biked. Are you making fun of me?
No. E-bikes-
Is my e-bike your mask?
That e-bike out there? Is that yours? It's fabulous.
Adam is too, No, that's not mine.
That's Dan's actually.
Oh.
Adam is to swim mask as Rich is to e-bike.
Another good slogan for our merch.
I've been getting on my road bike a little bit,
but I've got to back off the cycling also.
I'm all about the swim.
The swim is going to help your back, you know that?
I know I'm hoping that's the case.
And I would love to get some pointers from
a swim guru like yourself.
Maybe we can do a swim workout-
Let's do it.
prior to the next Roll On.
Let's do that.
Put you through the paces.
Let's do it.
Shout out Al Roker.
Did you see him out there?
I did not.
I see this link in the outline.
What is this about?
67 Years old.
He was out there in hurricane Ida
on a street.
But when you're watching him at first,
they have him really in tight,
and you just see waves thrashing him.
I know there's this video, (Adam laughs)
Roker pummeled by waves
as hurricane Ida targets New Orleans.
He stays on his feet.
And then when they pan out,
you see he's actually on a sidewalk.
Like he's not, it looks like he's
in the water, at first.
But he's actually on a sidewalk.
Cause he's a pro.
He's a stud.
Shout out Al Roker.
Yeah.
How about an Al Roker shout out?
Who doesn't love Al?
I don't know.
I don't know what he's like in his personal life.
Well, that's one form of endurance,
but we got a bunch of other endurance to discuss today.
Do we?
Because Enduro corner is back
with more high altitude trails and glacier dodging.
The sports you didn't know about.
(Rich laughs)
I know.
Hot on the heels
of the three celebrities you've never heard of
that will be competing in Malibu.
Sports you don't need to know about.
We took your celebrity spot; Adam, when you bowed out
of Malibu.
(Adam laughs)
They're like "Adam can't do it?"
Okay, let's get Rich.
(both laugh)
We'll go to Alexi.
(Adam laughs)
You guys are real celebrities.
You belong in that division.
No.
The Leadville 100
was this past week.
Heard of it.
Heard of that?
It might've come up on the show before.
Yes.
We've been talking about it because of Robbie Balenger.
This is an epic, legendary ultra race.
This past year, there were 678 runners
And Leadville; for those who don't know,
is at very high altitude in Colorado.
I think around 10,000 feet.
this run has 16,000 feet of gain.
Its highest point is at Hope Pass,
which is 12,600 feet.
And you hit that twice. It's an out and back.
Yeah. It's an out and back.
And Robbie Balenger used it
to complete his Colorado Crush.
So shout out to Robbie.
Amazing, Robbie.
Yeah; I mean, over the course of the summer,
he just never stopped running.
Did the Leadville Marathon, the Colorado trail;
which is 500 miles, the silver rush 50,
then he summited all 58
of the Colorado peaks over 14,000 feet and culminated
with the Leadville 100.
Which is quite something.
I'm sure there's a documentary or
at least some kind of film that's being made.
Reese Robinson was following him around chronicling
all of this.
So, shout out to my team 10,000 brother from another mother.
Amazing. His post was great.
He said his first 13 miles, he was surprisingly
in good shape and he was like flying.
And then from then on it was like-
Just brutal,
very hard to get to 87 miles.
Like, hitting the wall at 13 is-
I think he only had like a day or two
in between his final Colorado peak and that 100.
It's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
How much is his total elevation gain?
Did he ever say?
I dunno.
that'd be fun to see.
I wonder if he's tabulated it.
Yeah, it's got to be just bananas.
Oh yeah. I mean, it's gotta be
hundreds of thousands, right?
Yeah, yeah. I know.
Yeah.
First in the race was Adrian McDonald.
He did this race in 16 hours and 18 minutes
which is just like insane.
(Adam laughs)
A hundred miles with that kind of elevation gain
in just over 16 hours.
It was a sub 10 minute per mile average pace
for the entire thing.
He won it by 40 minutes. So dominated.
Ian Sharman came in second.
He's a four time Leadville champ at 1659.
And third, and this is really the interesting story
from my perspective,
is Anton Krupicka; who's 38 now,
came back after six years off competing,
essentially, in any ultra race.
I think he might've done one thing here or there,
but nothing of any significance since 2015.
He's a two time champion of this race.
He won it in 2006 and 2007 and then kind of disappeared.
And he's somebody that was an initial inspiration
for my journey.
I mean, he's been around for a long time.
I followed him forever.
He used to do this blog where
he would share his runs and he'd have
these topo maps and show you where he was training.
And kind of like this;
you know, soul surfer of ultra running,
kind of; like, has a Ricky Gates vibe to him a little bit.
Okay.
And just, you know, somebody who I just think
is cool, like super cool.
And to see him come back and re-establish himself
by getting third in this race, I think is extraordinary.
And it's really.
And not that far behind second.
No, not that far behind.
I mean, he's been hampered by all kinds of injuries.
He's had all kinds of problems.
And he rock climbs and rides his bike.
But I just thought he was done.
I had no idea that he, you know, would make
this kind of comeback.
And I think what's cool and interesting about it,
Not just, you know,
aside from the fact that he's just
a cool dude and somebody that everybody wants
to see do well,
He's defied this sort of unwritten rule
that ultra running champions
have a pretty short shelf life when it comes
to maintaining their peak performance.
Like, there's a long history
of ultra running champions who come on the scene,
they're unbeatable, they win a ton of races
in a compressed period of a couple years,
and then really struggle to maintain that
or to stay on top.
They never are able to really return to form.
And I don't know whether it's because it's just too brutal
on the body or they overtrain.
I'm not sure, but the fact that he kind of took
this break and came back and just, you know, put his stamp
on this race, I think is really cool.
And it'll be interesting to see whether other ultra runners,
you know, it's like these ultra runners, they go,
they can't compete at the high level
in these races anymore,
so then they go and they tackle these FKTs and
do other types of adventures
like Timothy Olson, Scott Jurek, et cetera.
And you know, being 38 for Anton, I mean, I think
it's pretty cool.
What's the, like, who's the all-time leader
in victories in these?
I don't know.
I'm not steeped enough in the history to know that.
I'm going to get shellacked for not knowing that offhand.
I mean, there's plenty of people out.
I mean, Scott Jur-
There's lots of, you know, runners who go
on these jags and they win tons of races.
I don't know who's the most victorious of all time.
Kilian, maybe.
Scott Jurek, I'm not sure.
Okay.
But I should know that, but I don't.
And who won the women's side?
You can google that in real time.
Let's do it.
Annie Hughes won on the women's side.
She's only 23 and she's a Leadville resident.
That's pretty cool.
And she won the race by over an hour, I think.
In 21 hours and six minutes. So that's pretty cool.
So that's the Leadville 100 recap
followed by UTMB, which just went down this past weekend.
This is kind of like the ultra race of all ultra races.
It's a quite a big deal.
It's 106 and a half miles,
during which time you run around Mont Blanc
and you go through France, Italy and Switzerland.
There's 2,347 runners, just,
you know, a race that gets a lot of attention.
There's a huge crowd that shows up at the finish line.
It's very celebrated and quite, you know,
something to behold.
Just like epic in its landscapes.
But it started off with a dark note because this UTMB event
is not just the one primary race, I guess over the course
of several days,
there's a bunch of other races that lead up
to the big race.
And there was a death.
This runner died in a fall
at a race called TDS earlier in the week.
And they had to partially halt the race and.
You know, somebody basically slipped and fell off a cliff.
Yeah.
As far as I can tell.
And I think it's the second-
And people whoever was ahead
of that point got to finish and anyone who was behind it
had to turn around.
They had to go back.
And get a ride back.
Right had to turn around.
So such an awful thing.
And the second in a year that after that thing in China.
Right.
Remember?
I do remember. That was a different level.
I know. So that was horrible.
But UTMB still; you know, basically went off nonetheless.
And Courtney Dauwalter,
friend of the pod,
established herself as the true goat.
Amazing.
She set the women's record.
Breaking a record that was set on a course
that I think was about three kilometers shorter
than the one that she ran.
Incredible.
Which makes it all the more impressive.
She was seventh overall, including the men,
which is unbelievable,
and did it in 22 hours and 30 minutes.
So it's like amazing. Like she just dominated.
Dominated.
Congrats Courtney.
Yeah, and did it with a smile on her face.
There was some concern because she had
she DNFed at Hard Rock 100 due to some stomach issues.
Right.
So there was some concern that; you know,
that might happen again.
And I guess there was a point
in the race when she did start throwing up and thought
that perhaps she was having flashbacks of Hard Rock.
But after she threw up and started running again,
it all kind of settled out and she was fine.
Digestive issues are common on these, right?
I mean, did you ever have nausea or vomiting
on some of these.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's part of it.
You barf and then you keep going or whatever, you know.
Things are bad and then they're better.
Right.
But sometimes when the digestion stuff gets out
of control; and you see this in iron man a lot,
it's really hard to get it settled again.
Crazy.
Karl Meltzer is the winningest hundred miler
of all time, according to a website called Ultra Spire.
And I don't know how
how old this post is.
How do they qualify that?
Like, is it the most ultras that you've won?
'Cause you could go and win tons of ultras
that aren't the big ones.
This is he's gotten 40 hundred mile race victories
at least.
Wow.
So when this was posted, he's garnered his 40th back
in; it looks like, 2008.
Let's see, 2018?
No it doesn't have-
His could be 2016, could be 2018.
Someone could've passed him, but he's over.
He's got 40, at least, according to this.
That's impressive.
Mm hmm.
He is a beast.
And the most a hundred mile wins in a calendar year as well.
Shout out Karl Meltzer.
The men's victory
was nabbed by Francoise D'Haene.
A French, also Solomon runner.
It's his fourth UTMB victory just weeks
after winning the hard rock 100.
So he did the double that Courtney was attempting.
Right.
He completed UTMB in 20 hours and 45 minutes.
He's also got three kids.
And I guess he's like,
he has a vineyard or he's a wine grower.
How cool.
Yeah, I don't know that much about this guy,
but that's pretty cool.
I mean, fourth UTMB victory.
That's unbelievable.
So, huge weekend for Solomon.
That's why I'm rocking the Solomon t-shirt today.
Shout out my Solomon.
It's embarrassing for me.
Oh, my Solomon teammates.
Like, are you kidding?
(Adam laughs)
And Camille Bruyas,
I think Bruyas,
I think that's how you say her last name,
was the second woman, who's also a Solomon athlete.
Is she American?
I don't know. I don't think so.
Let me live Google that.
She's not. I don't think she is, no.
But among the Americans-
French.
Yeah, French. Camille's French.
Among the Americans,
Jim Walmsley and Tim Tollefson both dropped out.
They're both beasts in their own right.
Unbelievable runners. Both of them.
Amazing.
And Jim, I think, was on track to do-
He was way up there.
And seemed really relaxed and, you know,
in contention but didn't work out for him.
Which is the way it goes with these things.
Final thing to discuss in our Enduro corner
is this 24 hour world record that was set over the weekend.
What? I missed that.
So it was this 24 hour race
in Poland called Ultra Park Weekend.
And this guy; who had never heard of before,
Sonia Sorokin, who's Lithuanian, broke
the 24 hour record
that was set by this guy,
this Greek dude, Yiannis Kouros,
that was considered untouchable.
That guy Kouros had run
188.5 miles
(Adam laughs)
in 1997.
In 24 hours.
Yeah. And and Sonia ran
192.25 miles
on like a one mile loop.
Yeesh!
So for context, that's averaging 7:29 per mile
for 24 hours straight.
Good Lord.
Which is unbelievable.
So he improved on Kouros record by six kilometers.
When Kouros ran 188, that was on a track, actually,
and he did 180 on road.
So this I think was on a path.
Sorokin's loop was like a one mile
like a paved path.
So it was kinda not a road, but not a track either.
Yep.
But unbelievable.
Hmm.
Unbelievable.
Did he have Pacers, like when Kipchoge got his record?
I mean, I'm sure, right?
I don't know, but I will say
if you're interested in diving deep
into this stuff, a great resource is: Irunfar.com.
I mean; basically, if you want to learn more
about UTMB or Leadville or this 24 hour world record,
or all things ultra running.
Irunfar.com, you know, basically is where you go
to learn everything you want to know.
Nice.
How's the live Googling going for you?
Do you enjoy it?
I do.
It's feeling very Rogan-esque.
We don't have a Jamie.
You're the Jamie, right?
I am.
So pull that up, Adam.
(Adam laughs)
Hey, can you pull that up for me?
I think you're on it.
Huh?
Let's talk about Lewis Pugh.
Do we have an update on him?
We do.
He's doing this Code Red Arctic swim
in Speedo diplomacy.
Right.
It started, I believe, on the 24th or-
Yeah, 25th it started.
So today's technically the sixth day.
But as of yesterday, I think it was the fifth day.
He's only been able to swim two of those days because of,
so I'll get into that.
So the first day he swam just under a kilometer.
He did about 500 meters
in the morning.
Another 490 in the afternoon
in zero degree water.
Like; literally.
Zero Celsius.
Zero degrees Celsius.
So 32 degrees Fahrenheit.
So it's just, it's like 0.1 degrees warmer than freezing.
And no wetsuits.
No wetsuit, no swim mask.
Goggles and Speedo and a swim cap.
Just the typical open-water uniform.
And so he can only be in there 10 minutes at a time,
so they've decided to do this,
so he goes in there, he gets out,
it takes them two to two and a half hours
to warm back up to his normal core temperature.
After 10 minutes.
After 10 Minutes.
He's got his, his lowest body temperature,
so far at, he sent me this two days ago, 95.7 degrees.
And so he's got a rigid, inflatable boat
with like a reinforced hull that sticks right by his side.
And that's what he's swimming with.
But you know, three of the days he's had problems with ice.
One of the days, it was just really fast moving, brash, ice.
Brash ice, and icebergs, brash ice is like any piece of ice
that's less than two meters across.
Mm hmm.
It kind of looks from above like that crushed ice slush.
Yeah.
And if you touch that with your bare skin,
it's going to have salt and all sorts.
It's going to cut you up.
And so, you know, you basically can't swim through that.
So in the second swim, on the first day,
he's swimming around brash ice.
He's swimming around icebergs.
He said, there's an iceberg, a thousand feet tall
that like is like cruising in his path.
So that's the kind of stuff he's dealing with.
It's weird; like, when he first was saying,
"oh, I can't swim. There's just, there's always floating
in here and it's too dangerous."
I thought like, well just swim around it.
But then he shared a video and you see this ice flow
and you're like, "Oh, now I get it."
Like, it's just, it's just packed with like, you know,
big pieces of ice that are floating that are just, you know,
there's a current and they'll just go right
into you and like hit you in the head.
He said the second swim
was like basically swimming across a highway.
Yeah.
And he was able to get through it.
It's like Frogger.
Yeah, it's like Frogger, except it's Lewis.
And then today he posted that like; literally,
he has the boat in the water, but it's surrounded by ice.
Like, there's just no open water.
It looks like the ice completely moved in.
So, you know, some of that
is it's coming off the main ice sheet and dumping
into the water.
So it's not necessarily good news
just cause it looks colder than, you know,
it looks like it should look, maybe.
But, so we'll see, we'll stay tuned with him.
I'm in touch with him.
We've been messaging back and forth.
The footage he has posted is just absolutely unreal.
Yeah. So you can find that
on either his Twitter feed or his Instagram.
Instagram is where you want to go.
And it's Pugh, P-U-G-H.
Yeah. He's posting; they're
kind of like two minute videos,
on there and then ultimately we'll see how it goes,
but that's what's happening on the Lewis Pugh front.
So congrats to Lewis. Thanks for doing it.
He's really raising the code red on climate crisis.
Yeah. Are you bummed that you're not there
in Greenland doing this?
Big time.
But you know, it was Zuma's birthday.
So by the time he was able
to get his plane organized and the timing of it.
Like, if Delta hadn't gotten into Greenland,
and he started on August 14,
there would have been time.
It would have been weeks ago.
I would have been there, yeah.
Mm hmm. Right.
Yeah.
All right, well thus concludes Enduro corner
for this Role On.
Do you think that we did it today?
I like Enduro corner.
It is right. It's good.
Yeah. It's very on brand.
(Rich laughs)
Do you think anybody else cares? I think so.
I think so.
Maybe. Who knows?
Anyway, let's take a quick break and we'll
be back with show and tell, the big story,
listener questions and more.
(wooshing sound effect)
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig
this podcast, then I think you'll really enjoy
my latest book: "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from, poignant essays by,
and glorious photography of some 50
of my favorite guests over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium
of the show and copious wisdom shared there-in
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it. (whooshing sound effect)
Adam, we need you back
in an actual reality, not virtual reality.
Rich. You've never looked better, my friend.
(Rich laughs)
I mean that.
For those that are just listening,
Adam is donning virtual reality goggles.
He's got Oculus-
I do.
On top of his head right now.
I'm deep in the Oculus.
Are you going to just remain there or are you going
to come back to us?
I'll come back to you, but this is a friend
of the pod's new projects,
which you've discussed with him.
I think you've even tried it, right?
Yes. Our friend Michael Muller.
He's got this incredible new VR experience
called, "Into The Now," which is available
on Oculus.
Where you can experience what it's like to swim with sharks.
Sharks, whales.
Uncaged.
Uncaged. Eels.
I wish you could see what I'm seeing right now; Rich,
'cause there's a beautiful view of a canyon.
So we; during the break, we tried to get
this thing sorted out.
We had to unbox it and do all the
sort of updates, software updates.
We're trying to get the whole thing configured.
It was taking longer than expected.
Sorry about that.
Which mimics the experience we had when Michael
was here, because we took a break during
that podcast so that I could experience what you're
trying to experience right now.
And it took a while to get it up on its feet.
But I was able to see it.
So I already know what it's like,
and it's quite extraordinary.
And this is available now.
Is it available now? I think it's still beta?
They want to send us something that's almost avail-
It's about to come out but it will be out soon.
I think it's, the idea is Michael Muller
is this great commercial photographer, renowned.
But has always been also an underwater photographer,
published an amazing book on sharks,
which I bought,
It's sitting right over there.
Yeah, yeah. The Tashchen book.
and his Tashchen exhibit was also equally great.
And this is basically, he always thought
that was two dimensional.
He wants to make a three-dimensional experience
to get people to see some of these animals
if they can't get in the water.
'Cause you know, he's going all over the world.
How many people are actually going to go swim with sharks.
Other than you, Adam.
You've made this a habit, a practice.
You don't need the virtual reality experience.
You're doing this.
(Rich laughs)
Well, rich, thank you.
Yeah, no, no, I've been very fortunate
to have been in the water with sharks many times,
but not great whites.
Other than being,
I am with great whites kind of,
but I haven't seen them
in the Santa Monica Bay.
You're among them.
I'm among them, but haven't seen them.
But there's whale sharks in here, there's whales.
I have been lucky enough to swim with whales too.
So yes, I'm fortunate that I've had all that, but you know,
once you've had it, you can't get enough of it.
You just want more and more of it.
So even me, I'm really excited about this.
I mean, if I had this at home and I could plug
in and just check out whales and sharks all the time,
I don't think I'd be in "R" too much.
I would just stay in VR.
That's concerning.
I know.
I'm with you. I think it's really cool.
And I've actually never really spent, I'm not a gamer.
I haven't spent time with these goggles on.
But just in the few minutes
that I was experiencing it during the break
is pretty impressive.
Yeah.
It's kind of amazing.
It's cool.
My problem is that one eye sees better than the other,
so even in this just now like,
Me too, but I think you can make those adjustments.
I mean, we were trying to get this up on its feet quickly,
but you can adjust the lenses on it
and just the setup process
with the minority report dashboard and the whole thing,
like it's pretty crazy.
I mean, I'm all
about lucidity and tactile real-world experience.
And I have a lot of, you know, fears about
where we're headed with all of this technology
that I think are well-reasoned,
but for experiences like this,
to tap into what it might be like
to have an adventure that you're unlikely to have.
I think there's a lot of benefit
and I can see this exploding into all areas of adventure.
And I think one of the things
that could be potentially most positively impactful
is the ability for experiences like this to breed empathy,
essentially by allowing people
to travel to places they wouldn't ordinarily be able
to go to experience different cultures and
to have a much more, you know, kind of profound experience
with, you know, worlds unknown
than they would otherwise be able to.
So again, it's technology presented
as an opportunity to bring us together.
We've tried this experiment before.
Right.
We'll see how this goes, but I'm optimistic for-
Well this has like
This piece of where we could take
this type of technology.
And that's; we talked about this with Muller.
Like, if you can go to visit, you know,
basically spend time with a village
in Africa and see what that would be like,
or be in, you know, Egypt or any number
of places all over the world and get a sense
of different cultures and different experiences.
Or with Alex Honnold, we were talking about rock climbing.
Like what does it feel to like, you know,
basically ascend, you know, a face,
Yeah.
And do what he does.
Wouldn't it be great to free solo
And feel what that must feel like.
Yeah free solo version
where you're like hanging on.
(Rich laughs)
I know, right?
Looking down.
I'm sure there will be all kinds of experiences like that.
But when it comes down to it, R is much better
than VR.
Yes. We all default to R.
But not everybody is going
to be comfortable swimming under water.
Not everyone wants to be in a scuba rig.
Not everyone wants to free dive or can.
Or is able to.
Yeah, right.
So all of that means there is,
there is a place there's a place for this.
Is it the gamification of adventure is that problematic?
Who knows, you know, there's always three moves down
the way.
But for now, let's celebrate this one.
Sure. And we love Michael and everything that he's about.
And this is quite an accomplishment and everything
that this guy does, he does with such attention
to quality and integrity.
So check it out. It's called "Into The Now,"
but is it, it's in beta right now?
Can you, so you can't actually purchase.
I had to email someone and tell them,
you know, that we need a certain,
I guess I think there's another app
that we have to download.
I'll get it all sorted out.
Cool.
And be back with you.
Right on.
But really excited about this.
I mean, I do believe that like he's doing
this out of the love of being underwater and wanting
to share it with people and it's super cool
that he's thinking that way.
Hundred percent.
Yeah.
Should we do the big story?
The big story.
I was interested when I sent you this article.
I didn't know how you'd take it, to be honest with you.
So the big story is based on an article
that was in the New York times.
An opinion piece
by somebody called Cassady Rosenblum.
And it's called, "Work is a False Idol."
And I think this is interesting.
It's basically-
It's lying flat, right?
I mean, explain it.
Yeah.
So, the idea is, there's this movement
that started in China where someone basically didn't
want to go to his job anymore and decided
to not show up and just lay flat.
And he called it "the lying flat movement"
and he was referencing diogenes.
Is it diogenes?
Diogenes.
In his, who was the original cynic,
back when a cynic meant
to live self sufficiently and in tune
with nature and not be interested in money, power and fame.
So now we've twisted cynic
as something who's always a naysayer or whatever,
but in reality.
In the same way that we twisted the stoic
to mean somebody who is like rigid and unemotional,
Right.
So cynic and stoic we've gotten wrong.
And this makes me really happy
because what it means is, which I've always known,
is I am a cynic.
Yes.
Luo Huazhang is the person who just decided
to tweet from his bed basically and then he's not
going back to work.
And he wants to spend-
Can you tweet and be a cynic, though?
He was reading and he wants to read-
That's not very Walden Pond.
No, but this is, he just wanted
to read and exercise and enjoy his life.
And he would do a job when he needed to.
He was opting out of like the,
they called it like 9, 9, 6 lifestyle in China.
In which is, I think it's six days a week or 9, 6, 6.
9:00 AM to 9:00 PM, six days a week.
That's it?
9, 9, 6, and-
Which was promulgated
by the founder of Alibaba, Jack Ma.
Right? So he's an anti, he's a cynic of Jack Ma.
And then she
was an NPR producer.
So she was a successful producer.
The writer of this piece, yeah.
The writer of the piece, Cassady.
And she was like, "You know what, I'm going home
to West Virginia.
I'm going to sit on the porch and watch hummingbirds.
I'm through with this news cycle."
And which is, you know, it's one thing
for someone who's trying to break
into media and as a young person to have that attitude,
but to someone who has seen success.
And I would say producing for NPR when you're young
is great success in this business.
And then to retreat from that is really interesting to me.
And she writes really beautifully about why.
And, you know, she points to the fact that Luo
is only one person who is talking about lying flat.
Casey Gerald, Casey Gerald, excuse me,
is a writer for New York magazine.
He's written a book; A memoir.
He's a black author who talks about
lying flat as rebellion.
Who basically, he opted out of the protests
to take care of himself and his soul.
And she links to an incredible essay
of his that I just got into this morning.
And it's incredible.
She talks about the nap ministry,
which is led by a woman and other black activists,
who's taking naps as kind of rebellion, open rebellion.
And she leads like clinics on naps.
I mean, you should be able to take a nap
without it being an act of rebellion.
She is like, all of this is basically, if you're,
if you're sleeping, you can't further
like the capitalist enterprise, you know.
Like there's a political aspect to what Luo's doing.
There's a political aspect to dropping out
like Casey did in his essay.
She's just pointing out that, and this is more widespread
than we think.
We have 10 million job openings
in the United States right now, highest in two decades.
People do not want to work.
Is that because wages are low?
If so then how come people
at Goldman Sachs are also whispering about
not wanting to work?
It's very interesting because
with the pandemic and the closing of so many businesses,
the logical extrapolation of
that would be people clamoring for jobs, right?
Like the sort of employers being
in high demand and being able to dictate terms
because people would be so desperate
to find a way to make ends meet.
And yet what we're seeing
is something very different all together.
And I think that's what interested me about all of this.
Like, okay, here we are in the pandemic,
there's, you know, with these predictions
of massive unemployment, there's unemployment,
but it's unemployment by
choice on some level.
And maybe that's because people are just, you know,
banking unemployment checks and reluctant to let go of that,
to go take jobs that aren't going to pay much more.
But I think also the impact of the pandemic
on how people are thinking about their relationship
to their professions more broadly.
Yeah. I mean, she was pointing that out too.
Like she's like maybe some of it is the kind
of turbo boosted unemployment benefits,
but some of it is also definitely a deep dissatisfaction.
What's that dissatisfaction?
Is it that,
you know, work has become too important
to our lives.
That like having a career define us
has become too important.
You know, is there something wrong
with the way we approach our work life and therefore
our whole life?
And I don't think you could look at all
this discussion of mental health.
You can look at, you know, suicide rates,
and, you know, antidepressant rates and drug addiction.
And you know, all of this,
there are a lot of dissatisfied people
out there and maybe the work component is part of that.
I think that's what this essay is getting into,
don't you think?
Yeah, I think so.
I think there's a generational piece to this as well.
Like me being gen X and the, you know, progeny of boomers.
I was raised to think about career in a certain way.
And what I see amongst millennials and gen Zers,
is a very different approach altogether.
One that's founded on, you know, pursuing what it is
that makes you feel excited and having a kind
of independent contractor relationship
with what you do, where you go from gig to gig.
And you're not overly tied down to any particular avenue.
And that of course allows people
to take long breaks and go on adventures.
And, you know, you see young people
like livin' the van life and, you know,
having the four hour work week experience.
or living in Bali,
and being digital, you know, kind of independent-
Digital nomad piece a part of this too
digital nomads and all of that.
And I think that's all super cool.
This is one step further to say, like,
"I don't want to do anything," essentially.
Right, so she also referenced a Twitter user
who posted, "I don't want a career,
I want to sit on the porch," and it got 400,000 likes.
And this person has 3,000.
I know. This is a woman who had like,
who has like 3,500 followers on Twitter.
It's not like a Twitter celebrity.
It's essentially like a fairly average person,
Right.
who tweeted this thing and it went crazy.
So certainly there's something afoot here.
How much of that is a reaction to
this current moment versus something
that's a little bit more generational or permanent?
I'm not sure we quite know right now, but.
But it's been going on for a while.
There's a book by Tom Hodgkinson called,
"How to be Idle," that had great reviews.
I found it through Dwight Garner,
who's my favorite literary critic.
I think I've mentioned him before on this podcast.
He's at the New York times and it's one
of his all time faves I think he wrote.
This book came out in 2005.
So this has been something some people have,
now he was kind of alone.
It kind of, the book is structured throughout a whole day.
Like 8:00 AM.
The first shot, I'll just read the first paragraph.
The first chapter is called,
"8:00 AM, waking up is hard to do"
And this is how it starts,
"I wonder if
that hardworking American rationalist and agent
of industry, Benjamin Franklin, knew
how much misery he would cause in the world.
When back in 1757, high on puritanical zeal,
he popularized and promoted the trite and patently untrue
aphorism 'early to bed and early to rise
makes a man healthy, wealthy and wise.'"
I've lived my whole life on that aphorism.
(Adam laughs)
Is it aphorism?
Am I using that word wrong?
No, I think I might've.
Yeah, like, okay, we're going
to have a revisionist history
on Benjamin Franklin and his approach
to life and work, like?
How dare Benjamin Franklin, you know,
basically pursue aspirational things.
Listen, now's not the time
to defend the founding fathers, Rich.
The childhood book
that I was given and read many times over
as a young person was, "The Early Bird Gets the Worm,"
and my whole life is all about the early bird gets the worm.
I've got a new life for you.
(indistinct)
"How to be Idle"?
"How to be Idle, A Loafers Manifesto,"
by Tom Hodgkinson.
Every instinct in me just balks at that.
You must read this then.
I know.
So here's the thing,
I think the healthy thing here is
is holding our relationship
to our work a little bit more lightly,
and understanding that who we are is not what we do.
And that's something that I struggle with
in an unhealthy way.
And I think probably most people of my generation,
you know, contend with.
I was recently, I'm not going to spoil it,
but I had a guest on the show
on an upcoming podcast that hasn't gone live yet,
who challenged me to take a year off.
A year!
At which I balked.
And they said, "Okay, how about six months?"
And it really made me anxious, in the moment.
Just being asked that question or being challenged
to do that because so much of who I am is tied up-
my identity is wrapped up in what I do.
And if I stopped doing that, what does
that mean about who I am, right?
And that goes into workaholism,
and how I think about myself,
and my attachment to relevancy
and you know, all of it, right?
And material things, right?
Material things, all of it like,
am I a provider? Am I a man?
Like, who am I, am I, you know,
meaningful if I'm not constantly putting content
out and all of it, right?
It challenges you to really deconstruct that
and evaluate that for yourself.
Which is scary for me, so I think within the context
of the conversation of work as a false idol,
there's important lessons to be mined about,
about, again, our relationship to work
in general and how we are all
in a culture in which identity
is so inextricably linked to what it is that we do.
I mean, it's a trope.
Like, you go to a party, what do you do?
And it's your career, right?
What does it mean if we reframe
that and ask a different question
or we let go altogether of attaching meaning
to work as a substrate for identity itself.
And I think as a thought experiment, if nothing else,
that's something important and healthy to do.
I'm not ready to, you know, be a loafer
and sit on the, you know, I want to do things in the world.
I have ambition and I'm not going
to feel guilty about that either.
But I do think having a healthy relationship with
that is important.
And I question how healthy my relationship
with that is right now.
It's healthier than it's been in the past,
but I think that there's, you know, more work
that I personally could do around this.
And I think that's why this piece like resonated with me
because it made me angry, you know?
Oh, really?
Yeah. A little bit.
Nice!
It's like, come on, like really?
Okay.
But she's such a great writer.
We're all gonna pat each other on the back
because we just want to lie down and we don't want
to go to work?
Well, I find it, like, it's an act of rebellion.
So it's like basically saying, "here's this,"
You know? Like do with what you want. She doesn't care.
She's on her parents porch.
But she is on her parent's porch.
Yeah, so parent's porch.
Right. Get your own damn porch.
Yeah, it's fine.
Her parents have to go to work and do that
so that she can lie down?
(Adam laughs)
I'm sure, you know, look.
Don't you think her-
What would Goggins say about all of this?
He would not be on team lie down.
(Rich laughs)
Right.
But I will say this,
So, if you look at the gradations of like American life
and work, right.
From the farm to the factory,
from the factory to growing, you know,
like the thing was to get into college,
and to work your way to the point where you don't
have to be working with your hands.
This was kind of like,
this is the mainstream culture, right?
I'm not saying I endorse any of this,
but this is how it kind of went.
And so then it became go to college
so you don't have to do what I did, son or daughter.
And you can look after yourself and have more, right?
It's all about have more, have more.
Then our generation came along,
and we saw that our parents who did these jobs,
if your parents are in the professional world doing like,
you know, teachers might find meaning,
but often lawyers don't.
You've had that personal experience.
Right, giant swaths
of the population who did that responsible thing
so that they could have the stuff,
but ultimately are unfulfilled.
Right.
And the kids know that their parents are unfulfilled.
And so the kids are like-
So the next generation pursue meaning.
Do what you love. Pursue what you love.
So we pursue it are what we love,
but then that becomes our entire being, right?
So like, yes, I got to do this.
This is who I am.
It becomes once you start your own business
or get into media or do whatever,
it becomes such an all encompassing,
you've had to fight so hard
to get whatever rung you're on
that you don't want to give it up.
And I understand that completely.
And it does become a little bit of who you are.
This is the next evolution of that.
Asking why is that? So it's really
just the same thing we were reflecting on our parents.
This is another level of that.
This is saying "Why are you like that?"
Isn't it a function of a dearth of meaning
in the workplace?
Like if people found greater meaning and purpose
in what they pursue career-wise
then work would not be the intolerable thing
that is motivating this movement
of rest as resistance.
I would put it this way,
Why does anything really,
(Adam laughs)
I hate to say this.
Are you going to get, like, nihilistic
on the cynics.
Yes! I'm going to go full cynic.
Anti-cynic.
No, this is full cynic.
I'm going to go full cynic.
What does it really matter if, like,
even Elizabeth Gilbert talks about this
and Big Magic's like, "No, one's asked you
to write that book," basically.
So Casey is saying, "No one asks you to do that."
Like, you don't need it.
The world doesn't necessarily need it.
Can you find meaning and purpose and fulfillment
without attaching it to doing something?
Maybe the do nothing theory.
Just the being.
So the book that I wrote before-
There's a Buddhist piece to this.
Yes.
The book I wrote before "One Breath"
was called "Middle to Somewhere."
It was a novel. Unpublished.
It got me an agent,
but we didn't get ended up-
it was like one of those almost not quites.
Didn't get a publisher. Still like it.
But the main character basically inherits
some money and decides to do nothing.
It's the do nothing theory.
And he travels the world just to like try
to do as little as possible.
And the idea is that you,
by doing, the more you do,
the more you're impacting the world.
You know,
the sub question is,
or the sub thesis is
beware of the unintended consequences
of good intentions.
The more you try to do to even fix something,
the more problems.
There's this article in the New York times
about cotton totes and how
an organic cotton tote needs
to be used 20,000 times to offset its overall impact
of production.
This is based on a 2018 study by the ministry of.
20,000 Times. What defines a use?
Just taking it to the store one time?
Using it 20,000 Times.
That means daily use for 54 years.
And that's for one bag.
And you think when you're wearing your cotton tote
that says, you know, "no more plastic bags"
that you're helping.
and yes, you're helping keep plastic out
of the waste stream,
but you're not, but there is this other use.
And, the point is like, even-
The point is, it's so hard to be good.
It is.
Like, even being good has a ramification, right?
It's the same thing we talked about
with the sixth extinction.
It's like the fact that we're even talking about this is a-
(Adam laughs)
So if we opt out of even trying
to be good and just do nothing, we'd be better off.
There is that argument.
That is the argument of Mr. Hodgkinson.
(Rich laughs)
Okay.
So with that, that person still needs to eat.
And they're either going to get a plastic bag
or they're going to use their cotton tote.
You still have to do things.
You can't opt out completely.
Listen, I'm not opting out.
I'm sitting here with you, but I will say-
You could sit under the Bodhi tree
for only so long before you have to eat something
or move your body or interact with other human beings.
Even Luo saying, "I want to lay flat,"
but he's also saying, "I want to exercise."
Like to me, for us, like swims
are the ultimate even runs are the ultimate
of, it's part of the do nothing.
It's not like you're doing nothing,
but you aren't producing anything.
You know, you really aren't, you're just swimming.
And there's something about these-
But you are doing something.
You are, but you're not, the do nothing means-
Everything is a choice.
Whether you're choosing to sit on the porch,
go for a swim, go to work,
use a cotton tote or a plastic bag.
You're making choices all the time.
So the flaw in the premise is
that you're opting out and not making choices.
Right.
And you're saying that is your choice.
You are making, that's an active choice, nonetheless.
And the cynic, I think, self-sufficiency
was a big part of that.
And you can't be a self self-sufficient
if you're engaging in the food stream.
Then you're not really the full cynic.
Well, nobody is completely self-sufficient.
Right.
We're all part of a greater ecosystem.
And we make choices about how we interact with that.
But I do think it's interesting
that there's this now resurgence of interest in cynicism,
in the traditional philosophical sense.
And I wonder whether there's a movement afoot
to modernize
the kind of philosophy of cynicism
to the mainstream
in the way that Ryan Holiday
and others have championed stoicism
into the mainstream, by writing books about it.
And there's a lot of overlap between cynicism and, you know,
Henry David Thoreau and these great traditions
of people opting out of the flow of society
to do something different
and find meaning outside of the constraints
of the rules that govern
polite society.
Exactly.
I love it. I love this idea.
There's something cool about that.
Yes.
But,
I don't know, man.
I mean, you know, I'm too old
to have valid commentary on this.
But I think it is a thing
when you see 10 million job openings and people just saying,
"I'm not going to take that job."
Right.
in a moment when you would think like everybody
would be clamoring for jobs.
And some them are doing nothing.
They're taking the unemployment and doing nothing
and that's fine.
And some of them are probably trying
to get their own thing going, which whatever it is.
It reminds me of that
this idea of do nothing and the consequences of that,
and what you're talking about cynicism.
Brings me to this article you sent me yesterday.
An interview with the Beyond Meat CEO, Evan,
what's his last name?
No. His name is Ethan Brown.
Ethan Brown.
Hedonistic altruism is brought up in that.
Yeah.
He brings it up.
Which is interesting.
So this was a article on Ethan
that was in the Sunday New York Times yesterday, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So Ethan friend, friend of the pod,
he was on an early episode of the show.
CEO, founder of Beyond Meat.
There was not much in this article
that I didn't already know,
or that isn't kind of like widely known about him,
but there is something interesting about the idea
of hedonistic altruism.
Which is in the title of the piece
that relates to this idea of cynicism.
Right.
I guess tangentially.
So Ethan's premise is, you know, he grew up on a farm.
He decided he didn't want to have to kill anything to eat
Why should I, I'm not an animal.
You know, just because animals do it
doesn't mean we need to do it.
And he's an example of doing something
that has actually had a net positive impact so far,
and that's getting people off meat,
getting them onto these meat alternatives.
I personally like eating the meat alternatives
once a week or twice a week at the most.
And I like it. It tastes good.
And I'm one of those people that does eat it.
And, but it's mostly for people who are meat eaters,
who are kind of gravitating towards.
And it is making a big environmental impact according
to some studies.
But in this article, he's like, you know,
"it used to be, to be ecologically conscious,
you had to go without a car or you had
to buy some crappy hybrid
and now you can buy a Tesla and isn't that great?"
That's hedonistic altruism.
But there is the unintended consequences
of electric cars booming,
which is good. It's positive. I love electric cars.
I don't own one yet,
but I do want one,
is there's a battery thing.
And there's rare minerals involved in those batteries.
And now there's interests that want to go try
to mine those minerals in the deep sea beds.
And there's, you know, land mining
that has all sorts of issues and complicated issues.
So, you know, what is 10 moves down the road?
What does that look like?
And that's what the do nothing people are kind
of pointing to.
Sure, but my retort to that is
that everything is iterative.
Of course, when you pioneer a new technology,
there are downstream implications of that.
Some of which are foreseeable and some of which are not.
the tote bag is a perfect example of that.
The lithium ion battery
is another example of that, of course.
But we have to move forward to solve these problems.
And so these are all steps and we have
to address these things as they come.
Like, it's better that electric vehicles exist,
and that they've been created in a way
that, you know, is aspirational for the consumer, right?
It's creating demand.
They're going to get cheaper.
There's going to be more and more of them
until one day we're going to wake up
and there really are no traditional vehicles
on the road anymore.
Yes, we'll have to deal
with the mining application, you know,
implications of that.
But are we not better off for making these changes?
Don't ask me. Ask Greta.
(Adam laughs)
Well, I mean, Greta would like
it all to be happening much more quickly.
By the way, I got criticized in YouTube comments.
You did?
Well, people thought I was making fun of her.
Like, I'm on her side. I was like,
I was sort of, you know, trying to channel her voice.
Remember when I was saying, you know, like talking.
Oh.
People thought I was mocking her.
I'm not mocking her at all.
Like, she's the one who's holding the hard line
and is frustrated that we're not doing
this quickly enough.
I just think Greta would not enjoy
the phrase hedonistic altruism.
Right.
But, you have to understand the psychology
of the human animal, right?
Like how are you going to get people to make changes?
Well you have to make that change attractive.
Right.
Whether it's the food,
whether it's the car that they're driving,
whatever it is like,
because most people
are not going to martyr themselves
or make the kind of choices
that Greta is making in her life
or that she would wish that more people would make.
I agree.
So how do you appeal to people's sensibility
to do the right thing?
You have to make the right thing the cool thing,
the affordable thing, the attractive thing.
And these things unfortunately take time and we're
in a race.
We're in a race to save the planet.
My fear is that we can't iterate
on these technologies fast enough
to keep up with
the rate at which we're denigrating the environment.
And wouldn't we all be better off
if we just all laid flat and then consume less resources.
Right.
I'm not a lay flatter, but that's the idea.
That's the argument, right?
If we all just stopped.
Right.
If we all took 6 months off.
Like, the early pandemic happened
and everything stopped for a minute.
Great example.
And the skies cleared.
Right.
And the pollution, you know, like, yes.
That's, I think, where the, you know,
if we just-
Universal human wage kind of element.
Adoption of cynicism, the philosophy.
And the lie flat movement
just intoxicated the global population
to such an extent that we no longer
we no longer found it
interesting or important to do anything.
If cynicism became the next political movements
But then chaos would ensue.
No, but the cynics would not,
would not vote for Trump as a voting block.
Yeah. But you wouldn't vote.
Nobody would vote.
You might vote.
That would be an action.
You would have to literally get up and do something.
No, one's saying you lie flat-
That is anti-cynic!
(Adam laughs)
You don't lie flat all the time.
This is not a functional operating system
for society, Adam.
(Adam laughs)
Adam the cynic.
It's a good thought experiment.
If you want to be, you know, Henry David Thoreau
and go to Walden Pond and write about it.
Or sit on your parents porch.
I think Henry David Thoreau
was actually at Ralph Waldo Emerson's house.
(Adam laughs)
He was sitting in that guest house.
Somebody was bringing, who was it that told me this?
I think Walden Pond
was literally Emerson's guest house.
I think it was Amanda Palmer when she was on the podcast
and we were talking about this
and she, her point,
we were having a conversation about how nobody,
I hope my memory is correct on this,
maybe I have this wrong,
but the conversation was around how nobody
does anything alone.
Like everybody needs support
and any victory is a team victory.
Even Thoreau had somebody bring him muffins,
like when he was out in the pond,
like he wasn't out there by himself.
Thoreau was glamping, bro. He was glamping.
It was a serious glamping situation.
(Adam laughs)
I think he was on Emerson's property. I'm not kidding.
Like, I think Ralph Waldo Emerson was supporting him.
Is that's true? I don't know that.
I think so.
I think Ralph Waldo Emmerson
was already wealthy and renowned
and I think Thoreau, he admired Thoreau,
and I think he was like one of his patrons.
Listen, it's easy to be a cynic on 450,
$450,000 a year.
Who's making that?
I'm just saying like, it can,
it's sort of, it's sort of,
is it not privileged to say I'm going to lie down?
I don't think these guys are making 450 but
I know, I'm exaggerating,
but I'm just saying if you're on your parents' porch,
or like, how are you going-
How are you gonna, how is this functional?
I think the point is it's kind of a monkey wrench.
So it's not implied to be functional.
It's implied as a mirror saying,
"why are we all doing what we're doing?"
And for that, for that, I celebrate it.
Yeah, yeah.
Because I think we all need to have
that conversation with ourselves.
Yeah.
And beyond that.
From, based on this, I mean, she's,
to me, it's an incredible essay.
I'd love to read more of her work.
And maybe it took going home in West Virginia
to have the space and time
to write what she really wants instead
of churning out kind of stuff, news cycle stuff.
It sounds like she was exhausted by the news cycle.
Listen, man, this last week was a news cycle from hell.
Yeah.
It's not only hard to be in it,
it's hard to be hearing it.
And imagine producing that all the time,
if that's what she was doing.
I don't know exactly what show
it references in this what show she was on.
But I, off the top of my head, I don't remember,
but just being a part of that,
being in that building when all
that's going on, it's tough.
And so now she gets to write something kind of
like trying to wake people up to the fact
that you don't have to.
You know, work doesn't have to be a career.
It reminds me of someone, you know,
we're going to get into the streams of the week,
but there's this YouTuber
that I'm just starting to listen to, watch, excuse me,
in love.
And he's got a YouTube channel called
"Crime Pays, but Botany Doesn't" and we'll get into it,
but he's just like, he is a train engineer.
He drives freight trains and then like cruises
into the desert and checks out plants and just dives in.
And it's an incredible deep dive
into the flora of wherever you are.
And wherever he is.
Like an engineer in the truest sense.
Like an engineer of trains.
Engineer of trains. So like, the idea is, what if,
what if work didn't have to be careers?
And what if work just had to be,
you make enough to get by and then you could do other things
to really enrich your life.
I think that's what she's saying.
She's not saying don't get a job.
I'm down with that. I'm down with that.
You know,
we should be working to live, not living to work.
Exactly.
Deep thoughts.
Deep, deep thoughts.
Transitioning into the news cycle.
Yeah, should we tread into shallower waters
to talk about the streams of the week?
Let's do it.
When we last spoke,
I was sharing how much I was enjoying the White Lotus.
You had a chance to watch this whole thing.
Yeah.
I got to say of everything that I've watched
in the last year, this has stayed with me the most.
I think I think about this show every single day.
I think it's a master work.
I think it's the best TV writing I've seen
since Mad Men, Breaking Bad, that whole era.
It's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
It's this incredible, are we going to spoil it?
Let's not, let's try not to spoiler.
Yeah, I don't want to spoil it.
No spoiler.
Limited series on HBO
from the brain of Mike White,
who is just an exceptional chronicler
of the human psyche in all its strangeness.
Credits: School of Rock.
He was the writer of School of Rock.
Yeah, School of Rock
doesn't really capture what he's about.
I mean, his show Enlightenment
is probably a better touchdown,
flashpoint for kind of his sensibility.
And the White Lotus is just
this impeccable, incisive dissection
of race, class, privilege, colonialism.
And done in a really contemporary, modern and
comedic way that you just can't look away from.
I mean, I don't know. What'd you think?
So I agree with you.
My favorite thing,
I was just kind of sketching notes just now
is what I love about it is
that nobody is likable.
Right.
And that's not ruining anything,
but there's no character, that's a hundred percent likable.
Let's put it that way.
Maybe there's one, maybe there's one,
but I don't even think that
the young guy is.
Nobody is likable.
And what I love about that is everyone
has something that you're like
a little cringey about, you know?
And that's great because
I'm so sick of work that makes that there's always
some person who's good and other people are bad,
and that's just not the way the world works, you know,
Like everyone has this in them and
to have these gradations of goodness and badness,
or kind of greed and selfishness,
and enlightenment
and have them within individual characters.
Some you're going to like more than others; obviously,
but nobody is ultimately that likable.
And that's what's so delicious about this.
So, I applaud Mike White because you don't see a lot of
that these days.
It's much more black and white, usually.
It's interesting how this all came together
during the pandemic under a very compressed period
of time as a limited series.
I wonder what would've happened had he had a runway
in the traditional sense where
this could go on for multiple seasons in the same location.
Given that it was sort of set up
to be a one-time kind of miniseries situation,
he has to provide an arc and finality for each
of the characters.
That ends up being, making it like as great as it is.
Like, everybody kind of comes
to their ultimate conclusion
in a way that really hammers home
this idea of like class and privilege, you know.
It's set at essentially the Four Seasons in Maui
that's called the White Lotus.
I mean, the show is called the "White Lotus."
It's like Mike White, you know, the lotus eater.
It's unbelievable, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's so infected with his sensibility
in the most beautiful way.
And the idea, I think,
is that subsequent seasons are just going
to be different White Lotuses.
Yeah. Yeah.
So it's going to travel.
In that idea
of the four seasons being like a brand,
it'll just be another location with a completely new cast.
I think there's some,
there was some news about how maybe one or two
of the characters might carry over.
I kind of hope not.
Armand's going to get reassigned?
I mean, you know, listen,
every performance in this show is pitch perfect.
It's unbelievable across the board.
When I think of any of these characters,
they just crush it completely.
Armand, you know,
if there is kind of like a standout, breakaway kind
of career defining performance,
you gotta give it up for Murray Bartlett as Armand
'cause he just, I mean, chef's kiss.
Especially in the finale what he does.
When he goes off the rails,
it's the most delicious viewing experience you can imagine.
Unbelievable.
And Steve Zahn.
I think it's the best thing you'll ever see Steve Zahn
at least to date.
It's incredible work for him.
Unbelievable.
And then your friend, you said someone you knew
or that who plays Steve Zahn's wife.
I forget, Cass-
No. I mean, I don't know her.
I mean, Connie Britton,
Connie Britton.
who plays Nicole Mossbacher.
I mean, she, I knew her a little bit.
Like, when I lived in New York city, right after college,
she went to Dartmouth and was friends
with a bunch of guys that I ran around with.
So, I mean, I haven't talked to her,
I wouldn't consider her a friend.
She's somebody I've met, you know.
Actually, met Steve Zahn when he was like a teenager.
Did ya? When I was living in New York.
I was a PA on an independent feature that he was in,
in the early phases of his career.
But I think like, across the board,
everybody's doing their best work.
From Mike White all the way down.
And
it's just
kind of an amazing
dissection in the most contemporary way
of our blind spots as a culture,
from the perspective of privilege.
You know, just the idea of being at a high end resort
in Hawaii, where, you know, at night
there's the luau's and the kind of, you know,
bring the natives out and make them dance
in this kind of Disney-esque,
you know, performance of
indigenous tradition.
And when you see it that way,
you realize how kind of offensive it is.
And the way that every character kind of pivots back
to their privilege in the end.
I mean, it's certainly about race as well,
but even,
you know, the most kind
of performatively woke characters,
the two teenage girls or young women,
pivot back to their privilege when pressed, you know,
against the wall.
You were saying that the,
the portrayal of the teenagers was like,
so spot on.
Yeah, I mean, as a parent of teenagers,
like it's just, the archetypes are just pitch perfect.
Yeah.
And those two actresses really great chemistry and,
Oh my God.
Have you ever seen a more
like invective with the eye roll?
Like, I mean, it's so unbelievable, right?
Like the terror of
those young women, you know,
and the ire that they carry is just, you know.
And there's like great intergenerational repartee,
and there's other characters,
and we're not even getting into.
Right, the way that the young women, you know,
relate to the parents and all of that
is all incredibly accurate.
And there's the customer who's like from hell,
there's the guests from hell, that's in this, you know,
that the staff has to contend with.
There's the, you know, the woman who needs
to have a million spa treatments
to feel good about her life is there.
But all these people,
me saying that is not really, first of all,
that's not a spoiler, but it's also every character
is a whole person.
Well, I think what makes it great
is despite the flaws
that these characters all inhabit
in their own way,
Mike White writes them with such depth and such affection
for them.
Like he still loves these people, you know.
In a certain way, despite their flaws.
And it allows like you open this
by talking about how none of these,
these are all terrible people, but still,
you kind of root for them.
Yes.
Right?
And Jennifer Coolidge's character,
ultimately in the end, like, you know,
the whole narrative about how she might invest
in this, you know, in this woman's,
you know, future spa,
like to get her out of the context
of working at this resort.
You know it's not going to work out.
Like, you know that's never going to happen, right?
But ultimately the way that Jennifer Coolidge
kind of delivers the verdict of like,
"I'm not going to do this,"
is in a way that we can celebrate for her
because she's setting a healthy boundary for herself.
So even though it's done in a way that's so.
But it's not, it's not good though.
It's not good. No, It's not good at all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And yet,
There's a celebration.
Jennifer Coolidge's character kind of needed to do
that for herself.
And her character is so; at first,
you don't even want to look at her
and by the end, you love her.
She's a genius.
The scene on the boat with the ashes and all of
that is like,
She's a genius.
It's masterful.
She might be like,
in terms of just a comedy actress genius,
like she's been great for many, many years.
I think Mike White has to get full credit
for these performances too,
because he's able to,
obviously he's pushing some amazing buttons
to get these incredible performances.
Right and these are all actors
who are now given the opportunity
with great writing to show how good they actually are.
Yeah. That too.
The one thing I would say is because there is
that commentary,
it is explicit the idea of indigenous people
in a location as prop,
even though that there's something to that,
that kind of doesn't feel right.
Like, you know, everyone has their has their choice,
but there's also some,
there's also some legacy there,
legacy of colonialism, that you have to reckon with.
I will say, having said that, like the local people,
the local Hawaiian people
on this show are still kind of props.
Like, it's not.
But that's the point.
I don't know.
They're interchangeable and they're disposable.
So when,
is it Kai?
The character Kai who pulls off
No spoilers. No spoilers.
All right, he gets into trouble.
And when the shit hits the fan,
like that guy just disappears.
Right.
And that's the point.
So you say, that's the point. Yeah.
It's purposeful.
It's to say that this doesn't really matter, you know?
And when the two young girls
are, you know, Paula and what's,
Olivia.
Olivia are having a conversation about this
and Olivia is like,
"Well, at least nothing bad happened
or something bad could have happened."
Right.
And Paul has to say something,
has to remind her like something bad did happen.
Yeah.
You know, it's like,
"Oh yeah, something bad did happen."
But does that really matter?
And ultimately, Paula pivoting back to,
Paula could have done something in that moment
and Paula's like, "I got to go to college
and I'm leaving and I'm not gonna,
I'm gonna like, pretend this never happened."
That's my point.
Like, every character and even, yeah,
so all the way down the line,
they all make choices that are, you know,
regrettable and you're watching it in real time.
Yeah.
The one character that
has the amazing kind of celebratory arc
is Quinn the young son who we're not going to spoil it,
but like, he's the only one who kind of breaks free
from all of these constraints.
Yes.
In a positive way.
He's the one that yeah,
that Mike White takes care of the most,
I think, in terms of his outcome.
Right.
But like, I mean, you could say his dad too,
but I, you know, we don't want to spoil anymore,
but I thought like, it's so interesting
to see that Mike White,
there's this whole reality TV aspect of it.
Like, you know, he's a reality TV obsessive.
One of the bellman is someone he met on survivor.
Yeah.
(Adam laughs)
And yeah, well, I mean, he's a legendary contestant
on the amazing race and he's obsessed with reality TV,
and when you see like Connie Britton's character,
like you see a little bit of "The Housewives of",
you know, kind of, you know, vain
like being expressed through that.
And those that's a medium
in which you kind of hate these people,
but you fall in love with them too.
And it's confusing.
And all of the reality TV media, you know,
it is kind of all like that.
Like, and I think that Mike White came
in second on survivor on some celebrity survivor
or something.
Oh, he did?
I think so.
I didn't know that.
And I think he met-
I saw Mike White in Hawaii once.
Did you?
Which is weird, makes it very meta.
You gotta get him on the pod.
I would love to have him on.
I'd also love, I'd love to have Jake Lacy on too.
Jake Lacy, who is, I think another breakout performance
in this show.
Holla at ya boy.
(cross talk drowns out Adam)
Amazing performance by him.
So, I mean, this show is incredible
if you haven't watched it,
I guess all we're saying
is make time to watch it.
My boys, like, loved it.
They just want to talk about it like, all the time.
We started re-watching it,
my parents were in town for Zuma's birthday,
and we watched the first couple
of episodes again with them.
And who knows, maybe we'll keep going.
Yeah.
It's a re-watchable.
How about the score?
The music's spectacular.
The music is unbelievable.
So full of tension and anxiety, all that.
Tropical anxiety.
And what's the Saturday Night Live alum who comes
in as Shane's mother.
Molly Shannon.
Oh my god.
(both laugh)
All time fingernails on the chalkboard performance.
I know.
But then you understand why Jake Lacy's character
is the way that he is.
And it allows you to feel the slightest bit
of compassion for this very, you know, like sort of,
you know, broken human being.
And Armand is the all-time anti-hero.
You know, I thought-
His performance is so legendary
in this show that now you're seeing memes of him,
like everywhere all over the internet,
Like the whole world's fell in love with this guy
and I hope that his career just explodes
as a result of this.
Like he should be in everything.
You know, he has that same kind of comic timing that,
what is that, Jojo Rabbit, the writer/director.
Taika Waititi.
Yeah, doesn't kind of have
that a little bit.
Little bit.
Funny and kind of off-beat and-
But how he has to switch gears and put
on the happy face and then just, he goes insane.
He loses it.
(Rich laughs)
As a sober person did,
the idea is he's sober and then-
Again, like, are we, are we spoiling it
or are we not. Let's just say he goes on one
of the most epic relapse.
Epic benders. Relpase benders.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did that hurt you just watch it
or were you enjoying it.
No, I'm like, I'm with you brother.
You know, he got pushed to the edge. (Adam laughs)
Good shit.
I was feeling it.
I mean, look, we can talk about this show for hours.
Just go see it or see it in the comfort of your home.
Yes. Or on your Oculus.
Actually, you can't watch it on Oculus.
For a 360 experience of,
of the white Lotus.
Let's talk about the Val documentary.
Dude. Go for it.
So you watched, you saw the first hour of it.
I did. I consume movies in chunks, now.
I hate to tell you movie makers but
I am a product of our shortened attention span.
Yeah, this Val Kilmer documentary
that's on Amazon prime right now.
It's called Val.
It was so fascinating to watch this.
I think most of us have a sense
of who we think Val Kilmer is
because he's such a icon of the screen.
And you realize in watching this movie,
that despite the fact that we know he's playing characters
in movies,
it's almost impossible to disassociate
that from who you think the person is.
And my, you know, realization in watching this movie
is just how different he is than what I thought he was.
I mean, I'd heard stories about him being difficult
and that's kind of the lore.
It's like, oh, he's super talented,
but he's impossible to work with.
And you kind of just leave it at that.
And you think about Iceman, and you know, Top Gun,
and you think about his Jim Morrison portrayal.
And that's about all I knew about this guy
other than that he has a son.
Iceman, and batman and Jim Morrison.
Who's now an actor and has been in some cool movies
like Palo Alto.
Okay.
But I really didn't know that much about him,
and it's a really beautiful,
I won't call it,
it's not really a documentary.
It's more an autobiography.
It's a version of his life through his perspective.
I dunno if he self-funded it or what the kind of-
Kind of like a kid, The Kid Stays in the Picture kind of,
remember that movie Kid Stays in the Picture.
You had really legendary documentarians
who were making that.
Yeah.
And they had a take on their protagonist.
Whereas; I think, Val, although there are directors
to this movie,
it feels like Val's the one who's at the helm of this.
And it's premised on all of this footage that he has,
this guy bought a video camera way before people were buying
video cameras and literally rolled camera on his entire life
and has, you know, insane amounts of footage
throughout his entire career.
In storage. Like they actually go to storage.
They go to storage and it's like
he's in this giant warehouse
and he's unearthing all of these tapes
that date back to like the early eighties.
And the documentary is an attempt
to string that together and craft a narrative
of this guy's life.
And you realize like he has a very interesting childhood,
his brother who was like his filmmaking partner,
drowns in a swimming pool, having an epileptic seizure.
And it has a dramatic impact on young Val's life.
And it's really the story of a very sensitive artist.
That happens right when Val gets into Julliard, I think.
Right, right.
Yeah.
He was the youngest person admitted
to Julliard at the time.
Yeah.
And really wanted to be a theater actor
and wrote this play when he was at Julliard
that gets put up, you know, off-Broadway
and then they put it up at the public, I think like.
And he's got this crazy footage of him backstage
on Broadway with Kevin Bacon and Sean Penn.
They all have to be like 23 years old or something like that
at the time.
Yes!
It's unreal.
They look great. It's so fun to see.
And they, you know, we don't want to spoil it,
but there's a great little back and forth.
And then you see him with, he talks about how on,
on top gun.
It goes basically through his oeuvre
Oeuvre?
"Of."
His "of."
He goes through like film by film,
and then intersperses some present day with that.
Cause the idea, you know, he's been,
he's had throat cancer surgery and he can't speak
without pressing his throat.
So he got through the cancer, he's cancer free,
but it took a toll on his voice box.
And now he has like a tracheotomy and he has
to put his finger over the air hole in order to speak.
And it's barely understandable.
So there's subtitles for every time he talks
and then his son Jack,
who's voice is remarkably like Val's,
Narrates.
Reads, yeah, narrates voiceover that was written by Val.
And he's fantastic.
And, so I'm left with kind of three things.
There's the, obviously the footage is number one
and his life story is very interesting.
But I'm also interested in how beautiful his relationship
seems to be with his children
and obviously this is a documentary,
but you wouldn't get that kind of collaboration
unless there was.
I mean he even lives next door to his daughter.
Yeah.
Who's an adult.
Yeah, it's very touching and heartwarming.
And then there's the idea
of overcoming a horrible health crisis
that he's says he, you know, he sounds terrible,
but he feels great.
This is kind of paraphrasing.
He seems to have made peace with it.
Yeah.
And then there's this some,
but then within all that is the artist himself
and the footage where he's in an acting workshop
with Peter Moss and where basically,
he gives, I think he does a Hamlet monologue
and the acting coach is pushing him saying like,
you know, "what was that choice?
Why did you make that choice?"
He says, well, he's basically saying, you know,
I never had the urge to kill myself.
So I don't know what that's like.
So I did X, Y, and Z.
And he's like, the teacher is basically saying
you have had it, you know.
And there's this idea of creation that kind
of hit home for me as a writer.
You don't have to have actually had it
to explore the feeling.
You don't actually,
there's no feeling,
there's nothing that has happened
on this earth that has not happened to you.
That's what he's basically positing, right?
Whether, how true that is,
I'm not going to debate.
I just think there's something beautiful
in the creative zone of that.
And giving permission to inhabit a space on,
you know, personally.
Even something you haven't experienced.
There's something there.
That's what makes actors great, I think.
And certainly there's something there
for all creative people to think about.
Yeah.
I thought that was cool.
Yeah, that is cool.
And then the audition tapes for The Doors.
Oh, I know the way that he kind of went the extra mile
to audition for all of these parts,
by creating his own; basically, mini movies
of him auditioning.
Failed.
He auditioned for Goodfellas.
Yep, fail.
And they're not just like him talking to camera,
like he creates a little movie.
So he fails at getting the Henry Hill part
in Goodfellas, he fails at getting the Matthew Modine part
for Full Metal Jacket.
So Ray Liotta gets him, Matthew Modine gets him,
and then he sends it to become Jim Morrison
and it clicks, and they're like,
but otherwise he would not have gotten the part.
This is after he's already been in some big movies.
Yeah.
So it's so interesting, like how you have
to keep fighting and that's another thing
to take away.
Yeah, and also
the challenges of, you know, being a movie star
stuck in the body of a guy who's fundamentally, you know,
a sensitive artist.
like he talks about being,
I don't know if you got to this part,
but what it was like for him to be Batman
and how challenging it was,
and the pressure to, you know,
kind of be a big movie star when he was interested
in parts that weren't coming his way.
And I think within that,
there is this conversation about, you know,
how difficult he was and they address it,
but they don't really give it-
I would've felt better
had there been a real honest reckoning
with that kind of narrative about his past
and had him like talk to camera and, you know,
acknowledge what's true about that
or rebut what's not true about that
because I think that's kind of what, you know,
'cause we're all walking around
or anybody who knows anything about him
is kind of walking around with a certain impression.
They do deal with it.
Robert Downey Jr. Kind of dismisses it.
They were in Kiss Kiss, Bang Bang together.
Right.
But I felt like I wanted a little bit more, you know,
kind of like real, like I'm at the, you know,
"I'm done with my, that part of my career,
like here's how I reflect back on that,
and here's what I would have done differently
or here's where I was misunderstood."
Because it isn't a documentary in which people
are talking to camera and sharing their perspective of him.
It's just archival footage,
and then following him around
as he's doing whatever he's doing.
And I think within that,
there is a sadness because this guy, you know,
lost his voice and could no longer do the thing
that he loves to do.
And now he's, you know, reduced
to going to Comicon and signing posters.
And he talks about how he had
to make peace with that and find
like gratitude in, you know, spending time
with people who, you know, are fans of his.
And how there's beauty in that
as opposed to looking at it like,
"Well, this is the bottom of the barrel
now that I have to do this."
And that's uplifting in and of itself.
But you see a guy who had so much more inside of him yet
to be expressed that will never be expressed in that medium,
but it's compelled him to reinvent himself
as a visual artist.
And now he paints, and he's got this studio space,
and he's opened it up to other artists,
and it's birthed this whole other kind of creative life
for him.
I mean, he was an Adonis and now he's like wounded.
Right, and to like
have to reckon with your ego
in that regard; as well, I think is interesting.
So, I don't know.
I thought it was beautiful.
Like, you know,
it's not the definitive word on Val Kilmer
because it is his perspective
on his own life and
it should be consumed and enjoyed with that in mind.
Not as like, you know, cause you can be like, you know,
"Is this the real Val Kilmer?"
I mean, this is the Val Kilmer that he wants us to see.
Right. And I enjoyed it very much,
and I left that documentary deeply touched
and kind of in love with the guy.
But you could say the same thing
of the Michael Jordan doc, you know,
documentary series, you know, it was made by someone else
with a point of view, but it was obviously
with Michael Jordan's tacit approval
and there was nothing in there that Jordan.
And Kobe Bryant had a documentary.
And I love Kobe, rest his soul,
but like his book, I think didn't reckon with everything.
And you know, there's arguments for all of
these kinds of,
Yeah.
It doesn't mean it's not worth watching
because there is something there for you.
Right.
All right. Check it out.
Cool.
What else do we want to talk about?
The Alpinist is coming out September 7th,
I believe is the, and then it's in theaters.
That's a premiere.
And I think it's in theater shortly after that.
It's the new Red Bull climbing documentary
by one of the producers of The Dawn Wall,
which is, was the Tommy Caldwell
story of them climbing the Dawn Wall, he and his partner.
And this one follows Marc-Andre Leclerc.
And; basically, the idea he's a Canadian
that no one really had heard of, 23 year old
and he is a free soloist,
but, also, free solo, high alpine ice climbing.
So I think the movie starts with,
I watched it,
it's a beautiful movie.
The filmmaker's Peter Mortimer.
And; basically, it starts with Alex Honnold's voice saying,
"Is there someone out there that you, that you admire?"
This is during the press around Free Solo.
'Cause it's, you know, Alex has blown up so huge
and he cites Marc-Andre Leclerc
as someone to watch.
'Cause he's this guy no one's heard of doing stuff
that like, even Alex is like, "Wow."
And the footage is absolutely spectacular seeing him.
'Cause he's using equipment,
but with sometimes with no ropes.
Climbing waterfalls with no ropes
with like just a blade, like a centimeter blade,
into ice and hanging off with one arm
and just how slow, but also perusal,
you have to move to keep climbing up some of this.
The kind of third act revolves around
his amazing Torre Egger climb,
which is the first person to solo up Torre Egger
in Patagonia during winter.
And he uses ropes on that one.
And so, you know, you kind of see that happen.
There's a failed attempt, and he has to come down
in the middle of a blizzard during avalanche conditions.
And then he tries to get up again.
And then, you know, he, if you look up Marc-Andre,
you realize he's no longer with us.
And it gets into that as well.
But his whole story of being from a young kid wanting
to become this climber and then doing it
and living in a tent in the woods
with his girlfriend, Brett Harrington,
he's still the dirt bag climber.
It's not like it's post dirtbag.
Yeah it's-
It's current.
There's a purist,
I mean, I haven't seen the movie yet,
but from what I know of this guy, I mean,
he's the purest purest.
Like, you watch Free Solo and you think,
"Could you be any more purist than Alex?"
And here's a guy who is living in even more kind of,
you know, dirt bag, purest experience
because he's doing such death-defying things.
And really doesn't care if anyone knows about it
or sees it; like, it's purely for the act of doing it.
Some of the best climbing footage you'll ever want
to see if you loved Free Solo,
if you love Dawn Wall, you will love this.
And it definitely belongs in conversation with those three.
It's, you know, I think for most people,
Free Solo obviously looms above all of them.
There's a reason for that.
You know, you have Jimmy Chin,
an incredible cinematographer/photographer,
on the wall with them.
You know, so this is a little bit different than that.
There are great climbers following Marc-Andre around,
but sometimes they lose track
of him because he doesn't want to be on camera
until he's done the pure thing.
So there's that element of it.
And then you have the filmmaker struggling
with trying to locate him, which is interesting.
But it's not the same kind of collaboration.
Right.
But they are-
He's super young too, right?
23.
Yeah.
Wow. I look forward to checking that out.
Yeah, yeah. Beautiful movie.
Cool.
Yeah.
All right, man.
Let's pivot here.
I think we did streams of the week.
Yep. We streamed it.
What do we want?
Oh, you know what we should talk about?
What's that?
We need to; I mean, this is related to streams
of the week, we got to talk about the latest
in Matt Furie and news from the world of Feels Good Man.
I feel like Matt Furie, just plays-
Like this is like craziest turn
of events ever for this guy.
Let's go.
Well, you set it up.
Well, he,
there was an NFT.
Someone tried to create a Pepe the Frog.
Well, first of all, let's say
we talked about Feels Good Man many times on the show
with the filmmakers on the program.
So if you're not familiar,
you should check out that podcast.
But essentially it's a documentary about this guy,
Matt Furie, who is the artist comic book artist
behind this character, Pepe the Frog
that was then co-opted by the alt-right
and became a symbol of hatred and, you know,
all kinds of insanity that ensued.
And the documentary chronicles Matt's attempt to
re-secure, kind of, sovereignty over this character,
this frog, this green frog that ended up
in all these Twitter bios.
And, you know, symbolically means something
that he never intended.
To try to, you know, regain that
or to take it back and redefine it
through the lens of, like, his original intentions.
And so what happened with this NFT drop?
So yeah.
Sorry, I interrupted you, go for it.
Well, my understanding was there, there was,
it wasn't his drop, right?
It was like,
No.
So someone tried to put together a Pepe the Frog NFT,
and there was a-
Well, there's more than that.
There's like a whole, there's Sad Frogs District,
like there's this whole project
in which it's an NFT, you know, marketplace
that was listed as officially verified,
meaning they had the rights to kind of offer up all
of these NFTs that were kind of Pepe, you know,
related or adjacent.
Kind of like goblin versions of Pepe, right?
I guess.
Yeah.
You know, I'm not like an expert in all of this.
I mean, this is all based on an article.
A Vice article that we'll share in the show notes.
And there was, so basically the Sad Frog District
netted $4 million in training volume,
medium price of $450 each, right?
In ether, per sad frog.
In ether, whatever that-
Yeah, Ethereum.
Ethereum, okay.
Which is like the currency of choice in the NFT space.
And Furie, how did he, how did he?
Well, he's got these lawyers now,
'cause he's been on this campaign to, you know,
re-secure the rights to his original creation.
Yep.
So he issued, you know, basically a copyright
take down that, you know,
OpenSea had to acknowledge and respect.
So this was, you know, basically shut down
that whole kind of trading set,
you know, Sad Frog District, Sad Frogs District Trading.
I'm probably butchering this completely,
'cause I'm not steeped in this world,
Right.
but essentially it's shut all that down, right?
And where does that money go back?
Does he have to flow it back?
Well, that's the thing,
If you read this article,
like, it's controversial because a lot
of the people that were trading
in these things had spent money for these things
and they're out of.
Now is their investment
worth nothing, now?
It's worthless now.
It seems like the marketplace should have to pay them.
There's all this carnage, right?
And so there's blow back on Furie.
Like, "How dare you do this?"
But ultimately he, you know,
I'm siding with Matt Furie.
Of course!
Like this is his creation.
These people were out creating artwork based
on his IP,
Right!
and profiting off of it.
And he should have say over whether, I mean,
if you went out and made a bunch of NFTs with Mickey Mouse,
you don't think Disney's going to go after you?
Also, fuck your
bullshit NFT environmental, draining bullshit.
(Rich laughs)
All right. Like let Adam the cynic rule on this.
Who cares about your $500 NFT bullshit frog nobody wants.
Okay. Boomer.
The NFT thing, I don't even begin
to understand what's going on here,
but I can tell you that it's real,
and a lot of people are like making money
and doing all kinds of stuff here.
There's a lot of doing.
Eludes my ability to understand,
but it's certainly a thing.
But I celebrate Matt Furie taking a stand
for his creation.
Me too.
You know, getting it back.
And, not for nothing, profiting off of it.
Now he's like making millions of dollars.
After all of this!
Is he gonna make that money?
Finally!
Is he getting that money?
Well, he's offering up NFTs of Pepe
and he's making money, as he should, off of this.
Okay. So he's doing his own NFTs.
Yeah.
So, where is it in this article?
This article is pretty long.
There was one that went for like 4 million bucks
or something like that.
It's crazy.
Well, Matt Furie.
Well done, my friend.
So, good for him.
You deserve it.
Yeah.
Although it's still an NFT.
I'm not sure I'm in favor of it. (Rich laughs)
Yeah, the blow back here is interesting.
But anyway, it's good to see Matt Furie doing well.
I guess is the point of even bringing this up.
He took a lot of garbage.
I know. So that's cool.
You know, we've been joking
about how you come here right after you finish your shift
at Ben and Jerry's,
and there's a lot of speculation
as to whether you actually work at Ben and Jerry's or not.
(both laugh)
We're going to say with finality that you don't.
I do not.
Although, there is a bit of back to cynicism.
Cynicism in the, in the popular vernacular.
Being cynical about somebody who would work
at Ben and Jerry's.
Well, I was more being cynical about my choice
in tie dye wear.
Yeah.
But the joke was that like I'm wearing this tie-dye shirt
that looks like a Ben and Jerry's tie-dye shirt,
'cause it's really colorful versus the kind
that, like, the cool kind that everyone's wearing now.
But is there not a thinly veiled layer of like,
just snarkiness about like working a job at
an ice cream parlor.
Yeah. There is. There is.
There's a little elite cultural eleteism,
west coast elitism going on.
Enter stage left, ice cream Tiktok.
(Adam laughs)
Are you familiar with ice cream Tiktok, Adam Skolnick?
I am now.
You are now.
So I knew nothing about this until,
friend of the pod , friend in real life,
Joanne Molinaro, the Korean vegan,
responded to our snarky back and forth
about you, either working at Ben and Jerry's
or not working at Ben and Jerry's,
by alerting us to the fact
that there's a guy on Tiktok,
who works at an ice cream parlor
and mounts a camera; basically, you know,
in front of his face, like his phone,
so it's facing the ice cream
and serves ice cream to people
and has accumulated like 10 million followers
and is making,
Dylan Lemay.
Yeah.
Which is insane. And then-
He's now got 2 million subs, I think, on YouTube.
Does he?
Yeah, I think, let me look it up right now.
So then that turned me to, whoops,
I gotta turn that off.
I don't want to get in trouble here.
Sorry about that.
My friends, Colin and Samir, who are YouTubers,
who do a really cool show.
Everybody should subscribe to them. They're great.
They did a video about this called
"the Wildly Lucrative World of Ice Cream Tiktok."
And it's about Dylan Lemay and just this trend.
1.85 Million subs on YouTube.
and it's because YouTube has gotten into short form video
because of Tiktok.
They're like getting pushed by the Tiktok to get shorts.
And so he's tapped into that.
Colin and Samir are extremely intelligent, like-
They're great!
They really know how to handicap the world of creators.
Explain the business behind it in a really transparent
and thoughtful way.
Yeah.
They like their subjects. It's clear, which is good.
There's no cynicism involved there.
Unless it's being watched by me.
No, I really liked the video.
The one thing I'd say is like, even their merch,
like they do an advertisement for their merch,
and they talk about how they sold like 3000 or,
I forget what the number was,
but they made 15 grand off their merch.
And I would just say, I love Colin and Samir,
but just say no to merch
because we don't need more merch in the world.
There's enough merch.
The cynic.
I know.
Rearing up again.
Even if we-
Adam the cynic says "just say no to merch."
So I shared on Instagram that,
that friend of the pod, Brogan Graham,
friend of Skolnick, Brogan Graham,
dropped by the studio the other week.
Brogan.
Semi unannounced.
He was in town for a brief period of time.
And he sat in your seat and he said,
"Is this Adam's seat?"
He did.
Yes.
And he wore-
And I put on his shirt,
like I took a piece of tape, black tape,
and I wrote Skolnick on it and put it on you.
So this is gonna be the new merch line.
That was gonna be my new merch line.
So even if we created merch
with like a version of black tape
that said Skolnick on it.
You're not supportive of that?
Well, here's the thing, like if we're going to do merch,
you could do like the hashtag team swim mask thing,
which would be cute for our, for your,
our listeners and your fans.
The problem with merch is it creates,
it does create a lot of waste.
Like, you know, it's basically, you know,
buying into this fast fashion kind of gestalt
of how clothing is manufactured
and then quickly kind of discarded
Yes.
that we're trying to opt out of,
so I completely understand that.
And my wife, having been a fashion designer
in a past life, has explained to me at length,
just how much waste being in fashion causes.
So, I think there is an environmental footprint
to this whole merch thing,
as lucrative as it is for these creators.
And listen, I don't begrudge any creator who's trying
to make a living.
And I think Colin and Samir are fantastic at what they do.
I think they should have millions and millions
of subscribers,
especially anybody who's interested in the creator economy.
Like you said, they do a great job
of kind of canvassing that,
and making understandable kind of what's happening online
in terms of trends.
Yep.
And they do it in a very accessible way.
And they're both great filmmakers
and they're great human beings.
I've gotten to know them a little bit,
and I think they're super cool guys.
If they had millions and millions of subscribers,
maybe they wouldn't have to do merch
or maybe they would just sell more merch, I don't know.
There's no "have to do" with merch.
But there is this thing where
if you're a creator online,
that merch is like, you know, what you do.
Well, so there's an unironic so, so-
And listen, we've sold merch.
I have t-shirts and you know, we sell certain things.
These guys are creators,
they're creator enthusiasts, right?
So, they're going to look at a creator,
even like Dylan or whoever it is,
from an enthusiast perspective, which is good.
They're not looking at it from the "Adam the Cynic"
perspective that is vaguely sad that people
are sitting around watching someone scoop ice cream.
Even though I like the idea of educating people about
this interesting kind of ice cream from the Philippines.
I think it was Ube, It was, they were talking about,
and even though I liked the color and all of that, I get it.
But I also don't get it.
Like, do we need to be like,
why are people watching that?
Well, that's a bigger question.
Yeah, why are we watching that?
Clearly he's doing something
that people are responding to?
I know but-
So the question is,
why are they responding to that?
People respond to a lot of bullshit.
What is the need that's being met,
Right.
by this guy serving ice cream.
And maybe it's just, we need a little bit
of light, good news.
I don't know.
One thing that was interesting
that Colin and Samir pointed out,
was that he's,
so Tiktok barely pays these guys.
Like he has 10 million subscribers,
but it was something like he alluded
to low six figures.
It seems like,
If 10 million people following what you're doing,
making a living shouldn't be a problem.
And he's making a living.
He's making like 120 grand a year,
according to like the estimates that like,
based on that video that you linked to.
Commanding the attention of 10 million people
is much more valuable than that.
So then he did one drop on Snapchat,
and it sounds like he made close to that
with just one video from Snapchat.
So Snapchat's creator space offers more money,
and obviously YouTube is going to be more lucrative for him
at 1.85 million subscribers and climbing.
And he's looking in New York for space,
so the whole idea is he works at Coldstone.
So the joke that me working at Ben and Jerry's
and ha ha how funny that is.
And Joanne saying, "how about this guy who actually works
at Coldstone?"
And has 10 million people who care about him
scooping ice cream every day.
But, pretty soon, He will no longer work at Coldstone.
Right.
Because, at the time, I think he's only now
working there two days a week.
It's in LA and he's moved,
I think he's moving to New York and opening his own space
and going to create his own flavors.
And he's going to have like celebrity collabs.
Like he's going to have a retail ice cream place?
Yes. It's in that-
So he's going to continue
to do the ice cream thing. He can't like, let go of that.
You can't stop.
It's like (indistinct) still has to do hair occasionally.
Right.
Yeah. But this guy still has to make,
I think he really wants to make ice cream, you know?
He really wants to make ice cream.
So he loves ice cream.
What's cool about him,
what I loved most about watching Dylan
was that he's dreamt about owning an ice cream shop
since he was a little kid.
So this is like-
It's authentic.
Yeah, it's real.
So that's what I liked about him.
And the merch thing is just funny.
Like, I didn't realize how little you actually
had to sell to make good money.
Like, they talked about, they tell you,
they made 15 grand by selling,
I forget what the number was,
I think it was like 300 something items.
That's how, that's why people do merch
because it's don't have to sell that many.
And, but to me, I just was wondering,
I'm like, "Well, do we need that?" That's all.
Yeah, I know.
I feel ya.
Yeah.
Let's do some listener questions.
Oh! we're rounding third base.
We are.
Listener questions.
We're gonna land this prop seaplane.
You know where we're going first?
Where is that?
Manitou Springs.
Thank you for that question, Annie.
That's a big one.
I have a history with self-sabotage, do you?
You just seem-
Does smoking too much pot count for that?
Well, only if you're doing it purposefully
to ruin your life.
What about if it's unconscious?
Yeah, I guess you can,
you can unconsciously self-sabotage yourself, of course.
Yeah.
I think, you know, unpacking this is complicated,
but ultimately,
self-sabotage has to do with a deep seated belief
that you're undeserving of good things, right?
Like if you think that you're not worthy,
then when you approach something good in your life,
you will create drama
to destroy it,
to adhere to this narrative or this story
that you tell yourself about yourself
and your lack of deservedness.
I think it's something that
is rooted in, of course, fear of failure.
Like, if you sabotage yourself,
then you have an excuse, right?
Like if you conduct some self sabotage,
then you can say, "Well, you know, I didn't really try."
Or, you know, you're not really putting,
your opting out of putting yourself on the line.
But it's also about fear of success, just the same.
Like what would it say about the story
that you tell yourself about who you are
if you actually succeeded?
And that, for many people, is scarier than failure.
The fear of success. I think.
And so I think getting behind the urge or the, you know,
the compulsion to self-sabotage your life
requires unpacking the root
of that belief and deconstructing what led you to believe
that you're not deserving of good things.
That you lack deservedness.
And I think to do that,
you need to perform an inventory of your life
and identify the stories that defy that narrative.
Like, think of all the times where good things did happen,
or you were deserving of love
or whatever it is that you feel like you're lacking.
And then moving forward
is all about performing esteemable acts
because self-esteem is a result of the performance
of esteemable acts.
It's a muscle. It's a habit, just like anything else.
But it is a bit of a Titanic situation
and it's, you know, to turn it around,
like you're going to have
to practice this for long periods of time.
I dunno. What do you think?
Unpacking, unpacking the stories
that lead you into that pattern of behavior
then figuring out how to correct that action
or how to avoid those kinds of patterns.
Yeah, and it begins with awareness.
If you slip up, not beating yourself up.
Right.
For having slipped up.
Right, so Annie has awareness
that she's doing it.
A lot of people don't.
They're just doing it and they're not even aware
that they're sabotaging their lives.
Right.
So at least Annie has this awareness.
So I think rooting yourself
in that awareness around the behavior
so that when you're doing it, you can understand,
"Okay, this is what I'm doing."
Then it is what you just said,
which is not beating yourself up about it.
Trying to figure out why you were doing it in the moment,
identifying that fear
and then figuring out what the contrary action is
and taking that action as uncomfortable as it is.
Because I think,
it's about breaking the pattern
of this self-fulfilling prophecy,
because if you feel like you're undeserving,
then you perform the self-sabotage
and then you create the reality
that affirms the belief, right?
So you have to break,
there's a pattern that you have to break.
And I think humans being creatures of habit
and creatures of pattern,
like forming new patterns is difficult and uncomfortable.
But I think that that's, you know, the process
of trying to, you know, change that for yourself.
Yeah. I think you're right.
I think most people who self sabotage
are totally unconscious that they're even doing it.
So you're right about that.
They'll just do it and they'll be like,
and there's a weird kind of rush or release
with affirming the narrative.
Like, "See! See! It happened again!"
Yeah.
"I'm a victim."
Or, you know, "I never get the promotion."
It can't be love or whatever.
"See, another person broke up with me."
Yeah.
Like you create
that reality so that you can double down on that narrative.
And there's a perverse kind of like,
not euphoria, but maybe it's a, you know,
I'm sure there's a neurochemical release involved in that,
that, you know, anchors you in that.
And I think really concretizes
or makes it even more difficult to break out of it.
The fear of success thing
is something I always have a hard,
I've heard it before, but I'm like,
no, I'm much more worried about failing
than like fear of success.
Like what story would you tell me?
I've heard that before. I don't quite identify with it.
What would it look like
if you actually got what you wanted
and that's frightening.
What if my life got bigger,
maybe I'm not ready to handle that.
It's scary. It's intimidating.
Do you think that's mostly subconscious
or do you think that's conscious?
I think it's mostly subconscious.
Mostly subconscious. Interesting.
Anyway, that's a really good question.
That's a great question.
Let's go to Brian from London.
Wow. That's quite a story.
How great is that guy?
Yeah, unbelievable.
I mean, first of all, you know,
congrats on making those changes.
I mean, that's quite an arc, Brian,
and something to be celebrated in its own right.
And sorry about your brother.
I can't imagine what that experience must
have been like for him to pass away
at such a young age.
As to, you know, the ultra marathon question.
Look, you know, if you can do 60 kilometers,
you can definitely do a hundred.
I mean, that's kind of what I always say.
You've already done 60,
you know what you're capable of
and you've been training for 18 months for this hundred.
Like, I'm not worried about you.
I feel like you're being; perhaps,
a little bit neurotic about this
because if you've been properly training
and working out your hydration
and your nutrition and practicing that
in your training and increasing the volume
of your running to, you know, prepare your ligaments
and your joints, as well as your muscles and your heart
and your lungs for enduring a hundred kilometers,
like I'm pretty confident that you're going to be just fine.
In terms of the training,
it sounds like you've got that sussed already.
I mean, the training changes are pretty basic.
It's just a slow expansion of volume
and then figuring out your hydration and nutrition strategy,
which you should be practicing in your training so
that there's no,
you know,
unexpected things that are going to happen
with respect to that during the race.
Or if unexpected things happen,
you'll at least have some options to pivot to
because you've worked it out in your training.
I don't have to tell you that doing a run like this
is not about going fast.
It's about keeping going.
It's about persistent endurance.
As I said, in Finding Ultra,
in the words of Chris Hauth,
"The prize does not go to the fastest person,
It goes to the person who slows down the least."
And you're training your body
to slow down as little as possible
over the duration of this day.
Charlie Engle,
so the guy who just won Leadville,
he averaged a 10 minute, per mile pace, right?
It's not that fast.
Most people who are runners can run
can run a 10 minute mile.
Right.
But can you do it all day?
That's really what you're training for.
I mean, Charlie Engle talks about this all the time.
If you could run 10 minute miles
all day long,
then you can not only win Bad Water,
you can, like, crush the record.
So it's not about running fast.
It's about training your body
to be able to stay upright
and moving forward as efficiently as possible.
So I think the real leap here from 60 to a hundred,
for Brian, is a mental leap.
As much as it is,
much more than it is a physical leap.
Right.
And you know, the subtext in my sense
is the subtext in Brian's question
is him trying to talk himself into believing
that he's capable of doing this.
Did you get that?
Yeah, I can, I could see it.
I mean, what's kind of to train from 60 to a hundred,
like what's the biggest chunk
of running you think he'd have to do at once?
I think that, you know,
he's going to have to do some race approximation weekends
or doing back to back big runs
so that he learns how to run when he's tired,
or maybe, you know, running in the middle of the night,
so he's used to running when he's sleep deprived.
Acclimating the body and the mind to those sorts of things.
Like a marathon and then another marathon
the next day?
Yeah, maybe something like that.
I mean, there's only so much that you can run
without getting injured.
Yeah.
So there's a cap on the volume.
And once you've reached that cap
and I don't know where he's at,
because he wasn't specific about his training,
it's just mental, you know.
It's understanding that your body
is more capable than, you know,
we allow ourselves to believe.
And it's a thing, you know, it goes back
to the Goggins thing, of the 40% rule.
Like you're capable, you know,
when you think you're done,
you've only tapped into 40% of what you're truly capable of.
And that really is a mental game.
So it's about cultivating that belief that you can do it.
And, the process of cultivating
that belief happens during training.
Like, when you have a breakthrough run
or you do like a big block and you get through it,
that starts to root you in this sense that it is possible,
but you've done a 60.
So, you know, you can do that.
This isn't that much crazier than that.
And then it's about, when you're in the race,
managing the pain, managing the lows
that you're gonna face,
managing the unforeseen variables
that are going to kick up and throw you off your plan
and being emotionally resilient.
You know, weather that and manage that
because things change. You're going to feel like shit.
You're going to want to quit.
You've got to train your mind and your body
to continue to move forward and push through
so that you have some tactile experience
with the fact that these things change.
Just because you feel lousy now,
doesn't mean you're always going to feel lousy,
and, you know, becoming persistent and resilient
and flexible and all the things
that you want in your toolbox going into this race.
And I think your biggest asset; perhaps,
when your back is up against it
and you reach that point
where you think you can't go any further
is that you have a really strong why.
You have your brother and this charity,
and it's obviously very meaningful and authentic to you.
So, you know, when all is lost,
pivot to the why and remind yourself why it is
that you're doing this.
And I think your why is so strong that that's going
to elevate you
and carry you through whatever obstacles you face, you know,
across this finish line.
Beautiful. Well said.
Anything to add to that?
Not really, no.
I've never run a 30 nor a 60,
unless you count the 4 by.
But you ran 80 miles this month and swam 10 kilometers.
No, 10 miles.
10 miles.
Yeah, so.
Thanks.
I'm no Brian Marshall from London, though.
No, you're not 'cause only Brian Marshall
from London is Brian Marshall from London.
(Adam laughs)
That could be a t-shirt.
Yeah.
(Adam laughs)
All right.
All right, ready.
Let's go to Scott from Vermont.
Thank you, Scott.
You know, if I'm being honest,
I struggle with how to answer this question.
Because on the one hand,
like I appreciate his desire to try
to understand how to, you know,
kind of go to go the extra mile
and take advantage of certain techniques
that can be beneficial.
And there's certainly a lot that has been studied
and written about when it comes the benefits
of nasal breathing.
Essentially, you know, it helps achieve
what's called the "Bohr effect,"
which is about increasing your body's ability
to tolerate carbon dioxide
through slower, more steady breathing.
And I think practicing nasal breathing when you're training
is a good kind of like reflex to develop,
and perhaps it will help you
utilize oxygen more efficiently
and make you a better athlete over time.
But I also think that,
I don't know, you know,
where Scott is at in terms of his success
as an athlete or his accomplishments
or his experience, et cetera.
But I don't know any
elite athletes who are like,
"I only breathe through my nose."
Certainly when I'm swimming, I don't.
And when I'm running, I mean,
I try to inhale through my nose and exhale through my mouth,
but when I'm really up against it,
I'm trying to get oxygen into my lungs however I can.
Mouth breather.
Yeah, and so part of me,
like my resistance to this,
is that it feels like the final 1%
on the mountain.
When we should really be focusing more on fundamental stuff.
Like, you know, are we, are you training
as hard as you can otherwise?
Or how's your nutrition? How's your rest? How's your sleep?
Like, the big, you know, kind of foundational aspects
of optimizing performance.
Focus on honing those in first.
Stuff like nasal breathing, I think is great,
and it's a good kind of practice,
but only if it's on top of an already strong foundation.
If you're focusing on nasal breathing,
when other stuff that is more important
to be paying attention to isn't exactly locked in.
Then I feel like it's sort of like taking vitamins
when, you know, you're eating fast food every day.
So Nicholas Ramirez, Catalina swim/run champion,
until a world champion, I think at one time.
And is in the next week,
they're going to line up again.
Yeah. That's right.
He still sends me some training plans now,
we just restarted.
But at times what he likes us to do
is during the warmup,
whether if you're doing a run,
he always has a 10 to 20 minute warmup involved.
So it's usually 15 or 20 minutes.
So if it's going to be an hour or 75 minute run,
it's going to be a 20 minute warmup. So that's zone two.
And part of that is he likes you to nasal breathe.
Yeah.
So I think his argument, this is not me talking it's him,
I mean, I understand this is coming
from probably the James Nestor book "Breathe,"
where he gets into the power of it.
And I've tried this also, I should say, like,
I've tried to do nasal breathing when I sleep,
because I wake up in the middle of the night,
my mouth is wide open and I'm all dried up.
So I've put tape,
You did the James Nestor experiment.
Yeah, put tape on my mouth so
that I can focus on nasal breathing when I sleep.
Because, you know, there's like a sympathetic,
parasympathetic, nervous system kind of resetting
that goes on.
And then I wake up in the morning and the tape's off
and my mouth is wide open.
(both laugh)
Which shows me how much I need this.
So I'm not dismissive of this in any way.
Like, I understand that this is, you know,
something that we should be practicing
and paying attention to.
But I question like how, anyway, go ahead.
Yeah. I was going to finish.
Nicholas says, basically just do it then.
So it's in through the nose, out through the nose,
but just in the first warmup period.
Ten minute, maybe 15 minute.
Obviously, if you miss a breath
and you have to go to the mountain, it's no big deal.
And you'll find it's harder to keep
that pace doing a nasal breathing.
But after that, when you're really running and trying
to accomplish whatever your goal is for that day exercise
or whatever, then just go to normal.
That's what he would say.
Yeah.
Yeah. Have you ever tried to just nasal breathe
when you're swimming?
It's not going to work.
I can't because I have a mask on.
(Rich laughs)
I can exhale through my nose.
That was not a setup by the way.
I can exhale through my nose with my mask on.
That's, what's so great about my swim mask
is you can still breathe through your nose
in this particular swim mask.
Thank you for bringing it up.
Only in the exhale version though.
But, normally, I inhale through the mouth and exhale.
Yeah.
But even if I was in a pool with goggles,
I don't know that I would inhale through my nose.
I've never really tried it. No.
There is a, you know, there is a thing
that happens with your nervous system though.
Yeah.
Through, and I should know more about this than I do.
So I feel like I'm not really satisfying Scott's inquiry.
Scott, I've got a book for you.
It's called "How to be Idle: A Loafer's Manifesto."
Don't worry about nasal breathing.
Just lie down and do nothing.
When you're lying down, you can be nasal breath.
Should you be nasal breathing
when you're lying down on your parents porch.
Let me check. Let me check,
chapter
8:00 PM. Smoking.
(Adam laughs)
Yeah, Not helpful.
All right.
I think we're, you know, needing to land this prop plane.
Alright.
This sea plane.
Let's do it.
Alright.
I feel bad for Scott.
I feel like I didn't answer this question very well.
No, I mean, we gave him some, you know,
Nicholas Ramirez wisdom.
I mean, the truth is like, you know,
I could have done a bunch of research and said,
"Here's what you should do," and all this kind of stuff.
The honest truth is like, I don't really think about this
that much.
Okay.
When I do, I'll like, okay,
I'll do kind of like warm up exercises
and I do try to do this at night and all alike,
but I don't spend a lot of time thinking about this.
And maybe if we get anything out of this,
it's Scott reminding me that perhaps I should focus
on this for myself a little bit more so.
Or maybe, your answer is just mouth breathe.
Who cares? It's not really that important. (Rich laughs)
Yeah.
Nothing wrong with that.
Read James Nestor's book, Breath.
I have not read it yet. Have you read it?
No, I haven't.
Have you had him on?
No, I haven't. I should have him on though.
Yeah.
Maybe that's what this is about.
Maybe.
This will prompt me to reach out to him.
I think that would be a great podcast actually.
Yeah.
Cool. All right.
We did it. We're done.
How do you feel?
I feel good, man.
I feel good too.
Feel good, man.
You're not, but you're not banking those NFTs
like Matt Furie.
I don't think I'm going to get complaints
when people ask me at the end,
when you asked me how I'm doing,
I always say, "I feel good." Like at first.
Now I've changed my intro.
I've got to work on my outro.
Well, we'll see what you come up with next time.
Yes.
All right, my friend.
I feel good as well.
Follow Adam at Adam Skolnick. Leave us a message.
If you want your question, ineffectively answered,.
Yes, please, please.
We would love more questions.
Yeah. (424) 235-4626.
Check out the show notes on the episode page
at richroll.com to dive
into everything we talked about today.
Please make sure that you subscribe
to the show on YouTube, on Spotify, on Apple
On all the places. It really helps us out.
Leave a comment.
Share it with your friends and on social media.
And
that's it.
Let's thank everybody who helped put on today's show.
We've got Jason Camiolo
for audio engineering, production, show notes,
interstitial music, all the things.
Blake Curtis for videoing the show.
We got Dan Drake, our newest member of the team,
who's helping us out on the video side,
creating new content and all kinds of cool stuff.
We got Jessica Miranda for graphics.
We have Georgia Whaley for copywriting.
We have, A.J. also working with us on video stuff
and graphics and all kinds of cool stuff.
Grayson Wilder for portraits today.
DK for advertiser relationships,
Theme music, as always,
by Tyler Trapper and Harry.
Adam put the Oculus back on he's left the building.
Adam has, Adam has left the building.
I'm in a new dimension.
You are.
We'll see you in Ready Player One.
Thanks for the love, you guys.
See you back here in a couple of days
with another awesome episode.
Peace, plants.
(indistinct whisper)
(calm music)